Olá,
minhas amigas, meus amigos. Sejam muito
bem-vindos para mais uma live. A live de
hoje podemos chamar de super live, né?
Como ficou conhecida essas lives que têm
muitas participações especiais. Nós
temos então hoje uma super live sobre um
assunto extremamente relevante no dia de
hoje que é o autismo, o TEIA, né? O
transtorno espectro autista. Temos aqui
conosco o Dr. Lucas Pacheco, o Dr. Luís
Sterne e o Dr. Rodrigo Vinc para
exposições muito relevantes sobre esse
tema, super importante hoje em dia,
porque está aumentando absolutamente,
como vocês bem sabem, a incidência do
TEIA. Então, eu gostaria aqui de que os
nossos convidados se apresentem, eh,
começando pelo Dr. Lucas Pacheco.
Boa noite a todos. Eu sou Dr. Lucas
Pacheco, sou médico homeopata.
Alan, já começo apresentando. Me me
apresento e faço a minha apresentação
inicial.
Sim, pode ser. Pode fazer assim.
Vou projetar então que lá tem o meu
currículo resumido. Deixa eu projetar.
Perfeito.
Compartilhar a tela.
E pessoal, vocês vão dando aí o feedback
de como é que tá o áudio, tá? Vocês tem
algum áudio baixo? Vocês estão escutando
bem as aulas?
Dout. Ana Paula Rodrigues já fazendo
comentários aqui bacanas.
Boa noite, doutora.
Boa noite, Irma, Cristiane, Luía,
Wellington, Ana Lúcia, todos que estão
entrando nessa live. Pode começar, Dr.
Lucas.
Pessoal, essa live de hoje é uma das
mais importantes que eu que eu já fiz,
porque a gente vai juntar saberes aqui
de quatro profissionais que atuam na
área. Eu e a professora Gabriela, a
gente desenvolveu um curso para
introduzir o tema da homeopatia
integrativa no Brasil, focado para
autismo TDH, onde a gente trouxe uma
vivência da terapia CIA e HDT eh junto
com a nossa prática. Então, eu vou eh
apresentar aqui brevemente o meu
currículo. Eu sou médico formado pela
Universidade Federal do Estado do Rio de
Janeiro. Sou especialista titulado em
homeopatia pela Associação Médica
Homeopática Brasileira. Fui professor da
Faculdade de Medicina de Pouso Alegre.
Fui professor de fitoterapia da USP de
2020 a 2022 e também já dei aula na pós
de homeopatia da Associação Paulista de
Homeopatia de 2018. a a 22, mas o que a
minha principal função hoje, além do
consultório, eu coordeno a pós-graduação
em homeopatia da plenitude educação. Sou
convidado pela IBCMED, pelo Albert
Einstein, em várias outras pós, tanto de
medicina integrativa quanto de eh
homeopatia para para ministrar aulas
mesmo. E aqui é só para quem tiver
interesse, isso aqui é exclusivo para
para médicos, quem tiver interesse para
fazer uma mentoria avançada, né, os
nossos colegas aqui fazem parte, a gente
tá com mais de 40 alunos e são temas bem
atualizados em homeopatia. A gente tem
um curso específico para médico
pediatra, temos a nossa pós-graduação
completa em homeopatia e um livro sobre
febre que eu lancei em 2023. Agora,
adentrando a esse tema que eu acho de
extrema importância, assim como é o
câncer, o autismo também é um grande
desafio paraa medicina. Atualmente a
gente tem alguns artigos mais recentes
mostrando que autismo ele vai além da
genética, ele eh inclui também fatores
ambientais que a gente denomina. Por
exemplo, o que que pode interferir no
aumento da incidência de uma prola
autista, né, de filhos autistas? Os
artigos demonstram, por exemplo,
diabetes materna, a gente vê a exposição
pré-natal a hormônios, esteroides,
infecção durante a gravidez, exposição
materna a poluentes ambientais,
histórico familiar de transtornos
psiquiátricos,
idade materna acima de 40, paterna acima
de 50, são algumas das evidências.
Então, alguns artigos colocam essa
questão importante dos hormônios,
principalmente ali durante a gestação.
Ele pode afetar a neurogênese e a
sinapitogênices.
Lucas, desculpa, interrompei aqui, eu
esqueci de, eu não pus slides ainda.
Você tá colocou eles aqui, mas tem que
colocar. Pera aí. Pronto.
Ah, bem, mas eu tô foi
bem tranquilo. Posso dar continuidade?
Sim, dar continuidade.
Tá bom. Então, eu tava falando sobre
esse slide aqui, que é um artigo
científico. Aí eu coloquei no tradutor
automático aqui os os fatores que
aumentam a incidência de autismo na
próle, então diabetes maternos, eh
infecção, eh, durante a gestação, uso de
hormônios, idade materna e paterna, eh,
e também exposição à poluente ambiental.
Então, a gente tem alguns artigos aí de
2025 mostrando Ok.
Vocês
estão me ouvindo, pessoal?
Sim, eu acho que o Lucas
ele caiu, ele caiu, né? Acho que o Lucas
caiu. Ele tava apresentando e parou o
áudio dele parou e depois ele caiu, né?
Vamos esperar ele voltar.
Aí acabou a energia do Lucas.
Ah, acabou energia.
Então vamos dar seguimento. Depois ele
pode dar.
Espero que não seja Estados Unidos vindo
para cá, né?
O próximo seria o Rodrigo, né, Rodrigo?
Isso. Aproveitando então o que o Lucas
tava falando, que acho que tem a ver
muito com que eh ele tava falando, né,
desse desse dessa parte ambiental, onde
a gente também inclui o mercúrio, o
fluor. Eu vou mostrar aqui para vocês,
então, aproveitando só para me
apresentar rapidamente. Sou Rodrigo 25,
dentista integrativo e tenho a formação
parte no Brasil, parte nos Estados
Unidos, através da International Academy
of Oral Medicine Toxology,
ah, onde eu pude fazer o todo o programa
como biológico dentist, que eles têm um
programa para isso, assim como também me
tornei fellow dessa associação. Eu
também sou um dentista recour, onde o
Dr. Dutra, né? É o primeiro médico e eu
sou o primeiro dentista. Reverse
Cognitive decline in Alzheimer. E nós
temos uma clínica que tem essa visão
multidisciplinar
e entende a importância de nós
trabalharmos juntos com um braço dos
profissionais da área de saúde.
Então, a gente tem a boca, ela é muito
importante paraa nossa saúde. E eu vou
mostrar aqui agora para vocês, só
colocando aqui a a minha aula,
né? Mas eu acho que na minha BIOS fala
bastante sobre o meu currículo. Quem
ainda não me segue, por favor, me siga.
Dr. Rodrigo 25. Tá.
Deixa eu só achar aqui. Achei.
Compartilhar tela. Apresentar.
Então, só para Vamos lá
aqui.
Tá dando para ver aí, doutores?
Alan, tá dando para ver?
Sim, sim. tá na tela.
Então, vendo essa foto, fica muito fácil
da gente entender que existe uma conexão
dos nossos dentes diretamente com o
nosso cérebro. existe uma parte
elétrica, da mesma forma que os nossos
que quando o carro ele tá com problema
de pressão no pneu ou aumento de
temperatura, existe uma informação, né,
informando o painel, existe também
através dos nossos dentes. Então, toda
essa informação por onde ele caminha,
né, ele tem essas conexões que são as
sinapses e através dessa sinapses corre
a informação através dos desses elétrons
levando informação. Chama-se
bioeletricidade, que é a forma que as
células se comunicam. O cérebro se
comunica com todo o corpo passando pelos
dentes. Então, além de passar pelos
neurônios, né, que faz parte passar pelo
caminho da polpa do dente, também passa
através dos meridianos. E tem o trabalho
do voo, que vem mostrar isso, assim como
também da acupuntura todos esses anos,
eh, esses milhares de anos, né, provando
que realmente passa informação. E aqui é
a comunicação
desses dentes. E quem quiser isso aí
depois, só colocar lá no no meu
Instagram, Dr. Rodrigo 25, eh, gráfico
que a gente, a nossa equipe passa aí
para vocês, tá? Esse gráfico aqui de
comunicação dos dentes com os órgãos.
Então, claro que quando tem qualquer
tipo de foco inflamatório, infeccioso,
degenerativo,
aqui também acaba afetando o processo de
comunicação com esses órgãos.
Bom, mas como estamos falando sobre
autismo, eu acho que a que mais tem de
importante a gente comentar é que o
autismo ele tá muito ligado a ao flu,
não sou eu que falo, são trabalhos
científicos. né? Tem no na parte
odontológica uma parte que divide muito.
Então tem dentistas que falam que tem
comprovação, que faz mal e tem uma parte
que diz que não tem comprovação. Então o
que eu estou trazendo aqui para vocês
são apenas informações que eu não tinha
acesso aqui no Brasil e fui ter acesso
lá na International Academy of Oricine
Toxicology. Esse aqui é o QR code, né,
que já leva direto pra página da IOMT,
onde tem mais de 400 artigos explicando
tudo isso. Se fizer sentido para quem
lê, puxa que maravilha. Eu vou
apresentar alguns poucos aqui para
mostrar a relação, né? Então tem eh um
trabalho aqui que mostra que o fluor ele
eh a exposição ao fluor crônica, né, tá
relacionado ao autismo, efeitos
induzidos no metabolismo e na disfunção
mitocondrial e o estress oxidativo e a
inflamação, imunoexitoxidade
e níveis de melatonina. Então o fluor
ele vai petrificar a pineal diminuindo a
eficiência da isso segundo os trabalhos,
tá bom? Então, quem tiver interesse ou
ou contestar os trabalhos, fiquem à
vontade. Mas eu tô trazendo aqui
informação que eu não tinha e agora
tenho esses trabalhos na mão e gostaria
muito de compartilhar com vocês. Eu tô
falando isso porque existe realmente uma
grande divisão. Então, tô trazendo a
literatura aqui para vocês e quem tiver
interesse segue aí toda a literatura.
Então o fur ele vai alterar tanto dentro
da mitocôndrias como também vai aumentar
o estess oxidativo e a inflamação.
Toda vez que a gente tem inflamação,
toda vez que a gente tem um agente
inflamatório, a gente vai ter uma
resposta de defesa do nosso organismo e
isso pode acabar gerando uma eh uma
resposta do nosso cérebro, diminuindo a
aumentando as proteções do nosso cérebro
e gerando uma série de de problemas.
Então o alumínio ele também é um metal
que acaba interferindo, né, juntamente
com o fluor.
Ah, a gente tem outro trabalho aqui,
a imuno e citotoxicidade como mecanismo
central da tipologia e tratamento dos
transtornos do espectro do autismo, um
possível papel do fluo e do alumínio,
que eu só vou citar aqui, tá? Para que
não fique chato a aula.
Esse aqui é um trabalho que mostra como
que acontece na parte de perodontia. Ou
seja, quando a gente tem um processo
inflamatório ao redor da gengiva ou ao
redor do dente, a gente chama de
gengivite, inflamação na gengiva. Quando
é ao redor do dente, chama-se de
periodontite. Então, fatores
inflamatórios como pequenos pedacinhos
de proteína dessas bactérias, que são os
lipopolissacarídos, assim como pequenos
pedacinhos de bactéria, acabam gerando
um processo de defesa do nosso corpo que
vai ativar os nossos soldados, né, que
os macrófagos que vão gerar fatores
inflamatórios, que são essas citocinas
aqui, que vão chegar lá no nosso cérebro
e falar: "Atenção, estamos sendo
atacados, entrar em módulo de defesa". E
quando entra em módulo de defesa, tem
diversos fatores que vão levar a defesa
do nosso cérebro. Um deles é a ativação
das nossas células lá chamado micróglia,
que são os nossos soldados ali no
cérebro que vão falar: "Aqui ninguém vai
passar". E começam a pegar as placas de
betamiloide e criar uma proteção. Daí
eles chegam pra proteína tal, vamos te
vamos te enfraquecer para que você possa
implodir e impedir o acesso das
bactérias. Isso tudo acaba causando
também déficit de cognição, problemas
como demência, problemas como Alzheimer
e uma série de outros outras doenças.
Bom, então acabei de falar, né, como que
a parte periodontal e gengival vai
ativar isso através dos fatores
inflamatórios que aparecem na boca. Isso
também tá relacionado a esses fatores a
longo prazo podem também tá dentro do
nosso osso, pode também tá dentro dos
nossos canais. Enfim, a gente tem tem
também o mercúrio que a gente vai falar
agora, tá? Ah, que ele tá muito próximo
também porque ele tá nas restaurações de
amalgama dental. Então aqui só para
mostrar mais um trabalho mostrando o
fluor. Então a o fluor da mesma forma
que ele faz a florapatita que vai deixar
o esmalte da gente mais resistente, ele
também tem uma eletroafinidade muito
grande com a nossa glândula pineal, que
é feito também de cálcio. Então ele vai
petrificando e diminuindo a produção de
melatonina.
E aí a melatonina também tá eh tá tá
associada aos ciclos circadianos, ao
sono. E quando a gente não entra no sono
reparador, né, na fase REN, a gente
também tem uma série de comprometimentos
da nossa saúde. Bom, mais um trabalho
aqui que eu acho que isso aí eh é só o
pessoal pesquisar Flur, né? E naquele
primeiro trabalho que eu mostro, que tem
vários artigos mostrando, mas mais um
artigo falando que tá também
comprometendo que compromete também a
filoso filosofilo
fisiologia da glândula pineal,
né? Eh, também diminuindo a produção de
melatonina.
Bom, tem trabalhos que mostram que ele
tem uma um efeito negativo no
desenvolvimento intelectual,
principalmente de crianças. Existem
evidências há muitos anos que ele também
pode ser cancerígeno, tá? Como ele deixa
o osso mais forte, mais resistente, ele
também diminui toda a microcirculação.
Quando você diminui a microcirculação, a
micronutrição e a limpeza do terreno,
você acaba entrando em homotoxicose.
Isso vai levar também a problemas de
desdiferenciação da célula. Isso aí é eh
a gente dá curso disso para os dentistas
que têm interesse, tá? Quem tiver
interesse, só me seguir no Instagram,
que a gente tá sempre falando, dando
dicas e também comentando com os cursos
quando tiver.
Bom, aqui é para mostrar como altera
também o o na fase da glicólise, ou
seja, ele vai interferir lá dentro do
mitocôndrias, diminuindo o processo de
formação de energia. Quando para o
processo de formação de energia dentro
da célula, a célula para. Quando a
célula para, o tecido para. quando para
também a toda o órgão não funciona de
uma forma correta, então vai diminuindo.
É como se a gente tivesse uma cozinha
que começa a faltar gás, começa a não
conseguir fazer a comidinha pro nosso
corpo da forma correta.
Só para finalizar aqui agora, queria só
falar referente ao amalgama dental, que
também é um outro ponto, né, que é
extremamente eh
tem pessoas que gostam do amalgama
dental, tem pessoas que não gostam. Eu
gostava no passado, quando não conhecia
o sempre achei que era um material que
durava muito até entender que ele é 50%
de mercúrio. E esse mercúrio, quando ele
entra em contato com a nossa saliva, com
as nossas bactérias ou mesmo com
qualquer coisa que robe elétron dele,
ele vai virar um metilcúrio, que é
extremamente tóxico, porque ele rompe a
barreira do nosso cérebro, tem uma
barreira que defende e pode acabar eh
degenerando o as nossas conexões
cerebrais.
Então, o amor dental quando a gente pega
e coloca no microscópio, né, como a
gente tá vendo aqui, ó, tem um monte de
mercúrio sobrando aqui, que para mim foi
dito que não sobrava mercúrio, que
formava isso aqui. Mas olha só, quando a
gente vê nessa lâmina o quanto que tem
de mercúrio aqui sobrando, que acaba
sendo evaporado.
e ele acaba entrando como um organo
metálico dentro da nossa célula e acaba
tendo uma afinidade muito grande também
com o nosso mitocôndrias, além de causar
uma série de problemas, né? Então,
quando a gente fala de remoção do
mercúrio, a gente primeiro tem que
pensar no paciente, tem que pensar na
equipe e tem que pensar no meio
ambiente. Então, hoje em dia a gente com
essa parte do COP que teve, né, o Brasil
se comprometeu a extinguir o as
restaurações de amalgma dental
até 2036, se eu não me engano, de de
toda de todo de todo o Brasil, da parte
odontológica. Eu só não sei porque que
não pode ser feito antes, visto que já é
conhecendo que faz mal, mas cada um tem
os seus motivos. Eu só queria mostrar
aqui como nós fazemos aqui na nossa
clínica, né, para proteger tanto o ar
que sai daqui, que passa por um
aspirador que fica fora da sala, como o
mercúrio que é removido daqui e entra
dentro de um contêiner também fora da
sala que não é jogado no esgoto. Então a
gente realmente acaba protegendo o
paciente, fazendo uma restauração
funcional, bonita, né? E também de uma
forma que nós chamamos de uma forma
segura.
Ah, aqui a gente vê que o Mercúrio tá na
literatura relacionado a uma série de
problemas, perda de memória, ansiedade,
irritabilidade,
fraqueza muscular, declínio intelectual,
ele também tá relacionado aqui, ó, a
distúrbios do espectro de autismo, que é
isso que a gente tá falando, mas também
tá relacionado à doença de Alzheimer,
esclerose múltipla, mal de parkson,
pânico. Então tem trabalhos que mostram
que o mercúrio ele leva a pensamentos
suicidas. Então o trabalhar em conjunto
é muito importante de uma forma
multidisciplinar para que a gente possa
tá tendo resultados melhores, mais
rápidos, mais integrais e principalmente
mais longevos, né? Então imagina se o
psicólogo ele tem essa noção que aquele
hemógrama da boca, se a pessoa tem uma
variável genética que não consegue
colocar para fora, como o Cpox 4, o
apoio 4, ele pode acabar entendendo e
recomendando
auxílio do dentista para que possa ter
um melhor resultado. Isso também
acontece em todos os níveis, porque o
mercúrio ele extremamente ele para a
formação de energia. E eu coloquei aqui
para vocês alguns exemplos, né?
Então, a associação entre níveis de
mercúrio e transtornos do espectro
autista, tá na literatura, tá? Tem uma
revisão sistemática em metaanálise. A
gente vê níveis de mercúrio mais
elevados em sangue total. a gente vê os
resultados eh sugerem que o mercúrio
pode desempenhar um papel relevante na
etiologia do TEIA, possivelmente
relacionando alterações ao mecanismo de
desintoxicação e eliminação. Então, se
ele vai lá na enzima que faz a limpeza,
que é o Cpox,
que é o citocroma P450 e para a função
dela, a nossa célula começa a ficar toda
intoxicada e pode acabar causando um
aumento desse metal dentro do nosso
corpo com consequências seríssimas pro
nosso organismo, né? Essa aqui foi feito
uma experiência onde colocaram uma
ovelhinha que tava grávida, eh, 12 faces
de amalgama dental e depois de um mês
colocaram um mercúrio radioativo nele e
depois de um mês eh eles viram aonde o
Mercúrio passeou. Então, eu realmente
acreditava que o Mercúrio ficava só na
boca. Hoje, com um monte de artigos e
com vídeos e com hã relatos, eu
realmente acredito que ele realmente é
extremamente
ruim pro nosso organismo. Tem mais
estudos aqui. Esse aqui, só para
finalizar, ah, examinou o aumento de
exposição do mercúrio, amalgumas
dentários em mães que estavam grávidas e
verificou que quem tinha mais de um
número maior de seis amágas tiveram 3,2
duas vezes mais probabilidade de serem
diagnosticado com autismo grave. Então
são trabalhos que existem, estão à
disposi disposição de todos, né? Eh,
esse é o mesmo estudo. Esta revisão
encontrou 91 estudos que examinam a
relação potencial entre o Mercúrio e o
TEIA de 99 a 2016. Então são trabalhos
relevantes e que a gente precisa
tá entendendo melhor, lendo, se for
possível, para poder eh tá orientando os
nossos pacientes.
Ah, e a OMT também tem um manifesto
sobre o homma dental que tem 1178
ah
citações, né, mostrando que o amalgama
dental, inclusive tem 50 que dizem que
não faz mal, tá? Os outros eles falam
que o amor dental faz mal e que o
Mercúrio é tóxico.
Bom, eu só queria aproveitar e convidar
todos a participarem de um evento que
nós estamos organizando, que é o SIS,
Simpósio Internacional de Saúde
Integrativa. Temos esses grandes feras
já confirmados, pessoas que eu admiro
demais do trabalho e que tem muito a
contribuir pra gente. Então, se por
acaso você conhece alguém que trabalha
com essa parte de saúde cerebral, a
gente vai est falando sobre ah o reverse
cognitive decline, principalmente na
parte de memória, saúde cerebral e
Alzheimer. Então, se você tem alguém que
queira convidar, eh, já começamos o
primeiro primeiro lote, temos ainda
alguns do primeiro lote. Vai ser em
março, dia 13, 14. E 15 de março, vamos
ter a presença internacional de um dos
criadores, não é o Dr. Britzing, né, o
Deo Briting, mas é um dos professores da
sua equipe, que é o TIP Whitney, que foi
professor Dr. Alan Dutra, meu professor
e vamos ter a o prazer da presença dele
com outros 40 profissionais da área da
saúde integrativa. Então, contamos com a
sua presença aí e eu acho que era isso
que eu tinha para falar.
Então vamos
muito bem muito bem. Então vamos ter
agora a apresentação do Dr. Lucas
Pacheco, né, que foi aí boicotado pela
companhia elétrica da cidade dele, mas
ele vai continuar a sua brilhante
exposição.
Parabéns, Rodrigo, vocês me me ouvem bem
um tema de enorme importância e com
evidências científicas muito eh
importantes também. Realmente a minha
cidade inteira acabou energia. Eu tô no
consultório, a minha esposa disse que na
lá em casa também acabou, que é um
bairro bem distante daqui. Então vamos
lá. Vou compartilhar a tela com vocês.
Eh, compartilhar a tela, compartilhar a
tela inteira. Alan, veja aí se deu
certinho, se eu já posso iniciar a
apresentação.
Pode iniciar.
Tá bom,
pessoal. Perdão então pela
intercorrência aqui da queda de energia.
Eh, então assim, só retomando
rapidamente, esse é um curso que eu e a
e a professora Gabriela ministramos já
há alguns anos, né? Desde 2015 eu eu
estudo a terapia CASIE, que foi
desenvolvida na Holanda, e a terapia
HDT, que também foi desenvolvida, eh,
coincidentemente na Holanda. E a gente
desenvolveu o nosso método aqui com os
nossos estudos. Então, eh, quem tiver
interesse, e já falei do meu currículo
aqui, o professor Luiz, a gente tá junto
coordenando uma mentoria avançada de
estudos avançados em homeopatia, quem
tiver interesse. E aí uma, a primeira e
única eh, o curso de de formação em
homeopatia para médicos pediatras do
Brasil. aí do lado esquerdo, a nossa
pós-graduação, a única de homeopatia no
Brasil que ensina protocolo de ví com
álbum, terapia CS e HDT, método da
sensação e etc. E aqui o meu livro é
sobre febre e de tanto orientar os
pacientes da importância da febre, os
meus pacientes me convenceram a escrever
um livro, tá aí o livro. Então, eu eh
falei para vocês desse artigo dos
determinantes ambientais eh importantes
que é que vai além da genética para que
aumentam, podem aumentar a incidência de
autismo na próa. Então, diabetes
maternos, ah, exposição pré-natal ao
hormônios esteroides, infecção na
gravidez, exposição materna ao poluente
ambiental, que foi falado aí, né? É,
fluor, eh, mercúrios, né? e também
transtornos psiquiátricos na história
familiar, idade materna acima de 40,
idade paterna acima de 50. Então, a
gente tem esses estudos mostrando que
realmente eh exposição a hormônios
esteroides eh na gestação vai aumentar a
incidência de autismo, principalmente
por afetar a neurogênese e e a
sinaptogênese.
Então, ele demonstra esses receptores de
estrogênios, né, que tá envolvido com
aprendizado e memória, é parte de
córtex, pocampo e antiencéfalo basal. A
exposição pré-natal à progesterona em
camundomos fêmeas, ele induz a metilação
do promotor ER beta no cérebro da próle,
levando a redução da expressão do R bet
beta, inibindo a expressão basal de R
alfa e o sódio do Então o que que eles
demonstram? infecções maternas durante a
gravidez aumenta também o risco de teia,
né, de transtorno do espectro autismo em
descendentes. É aquilo que eu com o Dr.
Alan conversamos numa outra live sobre o
MIA Maternal Immune Activation. são
essas ativações, inflamações durante a a
gestação, influenciando, passando a
barreira placentar, influenciando o
cérebro ainda em formação. Um estudo
mostrou que a exposição à penicilina
entre 1 e 2 anos e meio aumentou a
probabilidade de TEIA mais tarde na vida
em 1,6 vezes. Então, crianças que tomam
muito antibiótico fica um alerta também.
É, se estuda de 2025. nos últimos anos,
o potencial de associação entre vários
poluentes aqui, como já citado, mas vou
acrescentar alguns outros como
pesticidas, eh herbicidas, poluentes
atmosféricos, fumaça de cigarro, dióxido
de nitrogênio, eh escapes de automóveis,
poluentes orgânicos, parabenos, né? A
gente lembra aí do bisfenol, parabenos,
etc. ah, metais pesados, chumba,
arsênico, manganês, cadmo,
microplástico, eh, e o risco de teia tá
ganhando atenção pelas evidências
científicas. Então, numerosos estudos
epidemiológicos estão enfatizando a
conexão entre a exposição materna e
esses poluentes ambientais na gestação e
o risco de aumentar eh autismo na
progue. Então, os poluentes ambientais,
eles podem passar pela placenta, eles
podem entrar no cérebro do feto ainda em
desenvolvimento. a gente vai lembrar da
neurogênese, sinaptogênese, depois que
nasce vem aquela formação da bainha de
mielina, tem todo esse processo e devido
ao desenvolvimento ainda incompleto da
barreira hematoencefálica, é um cérebro
mais vulnerável, a capacidade metabólica
é insuficiente. Esses poluentes podem
ter efeitos mais profundos no
desenvolvimento do cérebro fetal do que
em adultos que já t uma proteção da
barreira mata encefálica melhor. os
potenciais mecanismos patogênicos inclui
a desregulação de lipídios, ácido
grásico, aminoácido, metabolismo
microbiano, levando a neuroinflamação e
estress oxidativo, como já foi citado
aqui hoje também. Eh, então a gente tem,
na verdade, eh, o ambiente deletério.
Então, eu denomino de desordem sistêmica
o autismo. Então, eh, e é muito
influenciado pela toxicidade ambiental.
Acho que aqui ninguém tem dúvida do
ambiente tóxico que a gente tá, a nossa
civilização tá vivendo atualmente. E a
intoxicação, isso gera intoxicação do
indivíduo, isso gera na homeopatia, isso
aqui é um linguajar da homeopatia, chama
de obstáculos, a melhora do paciente.
Então na homeopatia, tá? Isso aqui é um
linguajar homeopático, a gente tem o
remédio de fundo, que é o antipsódrico,
o remédio constitucional que o homeopata
clássico prescreve. Mas neste método que
a gente dá esse curso no Brasil, eh, a
gente prescreve isoterápicos que removem
as intoxicações desses metais pesados,
por exemplo, os que foram citados aqui.
Ah, a literatura médica, por exemplo,
tem sugerido que a exposição a certos
metais eh pesados tá associado sim ao
aumento de TEIA, na incidência do TEIA.
Aqui tá citado nesse artigo, ele é de
2023. mercúrio, chumbo, cádio, arsênico,
alumínio, ele pode sim atravessar a
barreira placentária e ele afeta o
cérebro ainda em desenvolvimento. Então,
alumínio, ó, por exemplo, um estudo
identificou que níveis elevados de
alumínio no cordão umbilical tá
associado a aumento de TEIA. Eh, uma
revisão sistemática aqui de 2024 mostrou
a associação de mercúrio, exposição ao
mercúrio e diagnóstico de TEIA em vários
estudos observacionais. Então aqui são
evidências, né, científicas. Eh, todos
os meus slides têm a o o resumo, né, em
um ou dois parágrafos e e a evidência
para se vocês que estão assistindo
quiserem aprofundar e ler o artigo
completo. 2021, a exposição a metais
pesados como arsênico, cárgico durante a
gravidez pode aumentar risco de ideia.
Exposição arsênico, ó, 2022. Então o
BPA, a gente falou que do bisfenol, né,
aquele amaciador de plástico, é um
descriptor endócrino que tem sido
associado a alterações desenvolvimento
neurológico em alguns estudos sugere que
ele pode sim aumentar a incidência, o
risco de TEIA. Então, 2022 e 2024,
revisões da literatura identificaram
correlações entre exposição precoce ao
BPA, o bisfenol, eh, que aí, por
exemplo, a gente vai identificando na
literatura esses fatores e a gente usa
isso no nosso protocolo de homeopatia
integrativo como suporte. a gente
prescreve homeopatia de fundo, claro que
precisa pro caso andar, mas a gente faz
esses desbloqueios com esses
isoterápicos e distúrbios do
desenvolvimento, incluindo tos clínicos
epidemiológicos.
eh um papel fundamental para um
mecanismo de detox prejudicado na
etiologia e na gravidade do transtorno
do espectro do autismo. Então é muito
interessante os os estudos que que
mostram que os pacientes teia eles têm
uma capacidade de detox prejudicada do
próprio eh organismo deles. Por exemplo,
a metalotioneína,
que é uma enzima que faz detox do nosso
organismo. Existem evidências desde o
início do ano 2000 que pacienteia tem a
metalotioneína
disfuncional prejudicada. Então por isso
que você pega duas pessoas expostas aos
mesmos poluentes. Uma faz carga tóxica,
a outra não. Por quê? porque uma
consegue fazer um detox natural bem
feito, a outra não. Então, esses estudos
estão mostrando isso. Os dados obtidos
mostraram que pacientes com transtorno
do espectro autista tinham níveis
aumentados de chumbo mercúrio e menor
atividade da glutationa transferase e
concentrações de vitamina E. Ou seja,
gluta também ajuda no detox, assim como
a metalotioneína. Então, esses estudos,
assim como outros estudos anteriores a
esses, eh vão mostrando que esses
indivíduos têm uma capacidade detox
prejudicada. Então, o autismo aqui, o
título de de um, outro artigo, é uma
forma de toxicidade de chumbo e
mercúrio. Então, aqui a gente vendo que
essas crianças eh ao se fazer o estudo
tem um um nível alto de mercúrio e
chumbo na crianças teia, né? Então, é
pra gente ficar alerta com isso,
estudar, aprofundar os estudos.
Lembrando que em 1943,
e muito interessante, né? Eh, um
estudioso, um pesquisador nos Estados
Unidos e o outro na Áustria ao mesmo
tempo, o Léo Kenner e o Hans Asperg,
eles identificaram um novo fenômeno que
eles descreveram como autismo da
primeira infância, o Léo Kenner e e
psicopatas autistas, o Asperg. Mas a
gente tem também que lembrar da Grúnia
Sucareva, que em 1925
ela já identificou esse quadro clínico,
só que o crédito foi dado mais aí pro
Kenner e pro Asp, mas ela foi a primeira
a identificar o quadro clínico de
autismo em 1925.
Eh, e lembrando que olha que
interessante, quando o Kenner e o
Asperge lá em 1943
falavam que o a causa do autismo, esses
absurdem, né? A causa do autismo é a mãe
geladeira. Existia essa hipótese, né,
que é porque a mãe é muito fria, com
filho, o filho fica altíssimo. Os
absurdos desses que já tá totalmente
descartado, eh, ah, é, é totalmente
genético, essas coisas assim, né? Ah, o
Bernard Himlan, ele publicou um livro
revolucionário em 1964,
ele propôs uma visão que o autismo não é
estritamente genético ou não é causado
pela mãe geladeira, mas sim por causa de
uma união do transtorno biológico e
ambiental. Então ele confrontou a visão
da época dele na década de 60, isso a
visão de que o autismo era genético, mas
ele trouxe a visão que na verdade o
autismo ele tem causalidades também
ambiental. E aí se iniciou aquele
movimento Dan, né? Quando eu tava na
faculdade de medicina se falava muito
ainda do movimento Dan, derrote o
autismo agora, né? Que foi iniciado em
95 no congresso lá em Texas. Vamos
derrotar o autismo e tal. e visava muito
na parte da alimentação, da nutrologia.
Atualmente, eh, de 2010 para cá, o
movimento D vem perdendo muita força,
nem se fala mais nele, porque agora a
gente fala de abordagem integral do do
autismo. A gente une o que tem de bom na
medicina convencional, na minha área, a
homeopatia, a ortomolecular do dos meus
colegas e a nutrologia. Então, uma uma
visão sistêmica. Como a gente tá diante
de uma desordem sistêmica, a gente
precisa fazer também uma abordagem
sistêmica, porque o TEIA ele tem
alterações na comunicação,
comportamento, interação social com base
biológica. Ele não é uma doença, ele é
um transtorno. E muitos antigamente, no
início do diagnóstico, lá em 1943,
chamavam de doença, né? Depois passou a
ser transtornos. Alguns colegas
pesquisadores hoje já estão chamando de
síndrome. Por quê? você pode chamar de
síndrome autística, porque síndrome é
ligado a várias causas, ou seja, é mais
de uma causa, tem origem diversas e é
difícil fechar diagnóstico. Então,
alguns autores atualmente estão chamando
de síndrome autística, mas ainda o nome
oficial é transtorno do espectro
autista. Então, a gente vai lembrando da
nossa neuroplasticidade, porém tem a
carga tóxica que pode afetar o
desenvolvimento cerebral. pesquisas
mostrando que inticida no sangue de
mulher grávida eleva o risco de autismo.
Esse artigo aqui com 1 milhão de
gestantes lá na Finlândia, eles viram
que identificado inticida DDT proibido
no sangue materno, a mulher tinha duas
vezes mais chance de ter filho autista.
E por aí vai, né? A aí até o risco da
proliteia com aumento de pré-exposição,
né? A pesticida ambiental num torno de
2.000 m da residência que a mãe mora.
Então, mesmo que não seja eh na beira da
casa dela, mas se for a 2 km de
distância, ainda impacta e pode aumentar
a chance de autismo. Então, por isso que
é que a gente fica estarrecido. Por que
que tá aumentando de 1 para 10.000 na
década de 70? Era um um paciente para
cada 10.000 eh crianças, né? Eh, início
da década de 70. Isso foi aumentando de
forma vertiginosa.
Chegou agora no último dado do CDC, que
é o síntese deis control para um a cada
31. E eu já vejo agora alguns estudos
atuais de agora de 2025 mostrando nos
Estados Unidos um para cada 26, um para
cada 28. É estarrecedor, né? A gente tá
diante de uma epidemia que eh isso
impacta muito nas famílias, nos
profissionais. nos cuidados, no sistema
de saúde, eh, é um aumento absurdo, né,
de um para 10.000 para um para 31.
Então, a gente na integrativa denomina
dois tipos de autismo. Tipo um, que a
causa predominante é genética. Já desde
os primeiros meses, a mãe já anota
alteração. Fala: "Olha, o meu filho já
anoto alteração nele do desde o primeiro
aninho". E tem o regressivo, que é o
tipo dois, aquela criança que
desenvolvia bem todos os marcos do
desenvolvimento normal. E entre 12 e 24
meses, eh, tem a aquela regressão, como
foi falado aqui, ativação da micródia,
né, células imunes do sistema, eh,
nervoso central de função fagocitária, a
gente tem
o cérebro inflamado e uma desconexão
funcional. Então, a gente tem vários
artigos mostrando essa questão do
problema da poda neural, né? Não, não
vou me ater a todos porque isso aqui é
um curso, né? Eu tô mostrando slides
iniciais de um curso que eu que eu
ministro, mas para vocês terem ideia que
tudo isso tá envolvido, o intestino, o
tipo de bactéria no intestino que tem
que tá as bactérias no intestino grosso,
por algum motivo, essas bactérias migram
pro intestino delgado, causando também
alterações. Então, então tudo isso a
gente tem evidências desse eixo
intestino cérebro. Não vou me aprofundar
nisso. Isso aqui a gente também ministra
aulas e mostra esses artigos. E o
famoso, né, síndrome do intestino
permeável. O normal é o nosso intestino
ter a inteligência de absorver o que é
saudável e eliminar o que é tóxico. O
intestino permeável, ele cria fissuras,
ele perde a barreira eh e a seletividade
intestinal e passa a entrar bactérias,
passa a entrar proteínas inteiras que
podem ser alergênicas, né? a proteína
inteira ela é ela é alergênica e entram
produtos tóxicos também nessas junções
que estão separadas, fissuradas,
síndrome do intestino permeável. Então
tudo isso a gente tem esses estudos, né,
essa essa esses isso aqui é foto de
livro, isso aqui é um livro sobre
autismo.
Então ácido propiórnico, que foi citado,
por exemplo, a gente usa na homeopatia o
ácido propiônico isoterápico, e as
paralisias dos nervos cranianos, que
isso aqui é uma aula inteira, né? Não,
não vou me ater a isso. E lembrando que
o a neurogênese e a sinaptogênese, a
gente tem ali a migração neuronal e
depois que nasce, a gente tem
principalmente ali a formação da bainha
de mielino. E lembrando que vai ter
fases da poda sináptica para eliminar eh
como se fosse eliminar os neurônios que
não estão sendo utilizados e são
processos natural. Quando ela não é
feita corretamente, isso pode causar
danos. Bom, eu vou finalizando aqui para
já dar espaço pros meus outros colegas
apresentarem, porque aqui tem 100
slides, né? Não vou me estender e não
vou esgotar o assunto aqui, mas só para
mostrar que existem muitas evidências
que o autismo ele tem sim uma
concordância genética em torno de 50% e
uma concordância ambiental também. É
isso que que os estudos mostram, uma
associação também que tem a parte sim
genética. o o indivíduo, ele tem que ter
a predisposição, mas tem um impacto
ambiental. É isso que tem mostrado esses
estudos e, enfim, eh eh bastante
conteúdo, né? Tudo que pode aumentar a
chance de de teria, eh diminuir a chance
da incidência de TEIA. Os os estudos têm
mostrado isso, o que que é protetor, o
que que aumenta a incidência, mas o foco
aqui hoje é trazer o tema, trazer essa
discussão, o que que tem de novo e não
esgotar o assunto e formar prestitores,
não é essa a intenção, mas trazer estes
questionamentos. Eu agradeço aqui a
oportunidade por eh estar com vocês. Vou
passar a palavra. Deixa eu ver como que
eu
eh aqui
quem que é agora que vai apresentar.
Eu dei uma visão geral, acho que
trazer pro próximo apresentador.
Tá bom.
Depois eu quero complementar todo mundo,
hein?
Então, tá bom. Alan. Ó, olha só, mas eu
queria falar para vocês o seguinte.
Cada vez que eu assisto uma aula de
vocês, eh, do Lucas, do Alan Rodrigo, eu
converso com eles e tudo, eh, a gente
vai vendo como a gente pode trocar
informações interessantes, entendeu?
Então, eh, essa live a gente ficou
pensando em São Paulo, como é que a
gente poderia fazer
as lives em conjunto. Agora a gente tá
vendo que tá muito claro, Alan, isso pra
gente tá, Alan? Eu vou falar algumas
coisas, mas tem uns dois slides do que
que eu assisti a tua aula há mais ou
menos um mês atrás e que você fez a
síntese como a gente vai integrar
homeopatia molecular funcional. Aí eu
vou te dar o prazer para você explicar
esses dois slides, tá bom?
Perfeito.
Tá. Então, gente, a gente vai falar um
aspecto em termos homeopato, uma ciência
que existe há 230 anos, 500 milhões de
pessoas se tratam no mundo. Eu, graças a
Deus, eu faço essa ciência há 43 anos e
eu cada vez eu tô mais apaixonado e
queria passar alguns exemplos clínicos
de como o autismo chegou na minha
clínica e como o próprio tratamento
homeopata
ela pode ajudar nesse sentido. Então,
antes de começar a explanação,
eu queria falar uma situação clínica. Eu
sou muito prático, eu atendo todos os
dias. Eu gosto da clínica, né? Então
aconteceu há 5 anos atrás, uma criança,
mais ou menos lá dois meses, chegou para
mim e a mãe falou o seguinte: "Eu vim
para você indicado para uma outra mãe,
porque esse menino aqui de 2 anos, ele
toda hora tem crise de garganta,
sinusite, ouvido, eh já teve o tipo lá
perfurado, ele faz pneumonia, né? E eu
queria ver se o próprio tratamento
homeopata melhora, que ele toda hora,
todo mês ele tá tomando antibiótico
corticoide. Isso é comum na nossa
clínica, né? Tudo bem. Só que quando a
gente foi atendendo esses anos todos, a
gente trata há 6 anos quase ele. Eh,
além disso do do que ficou melhor, a
gente foi vendo nele que espaçou mais as
infecções, mas ele tava atrasado, ele
ele tava tendo uma dificuldade para
interagir com ele mesmo, interagir com o
pai, com a mãe, com com a irmã. E a
gente fez uma suspeita de autismo
confirmado depois, né? E a mãe falou:
"Eu já tô satisfeito lá eh do que que
você tá tratando". Mas internamente eu
não tava satisfeito porque eu queria que
essa criança interagisse melhor com ela
mesmo, ela interagisse melhor, entendeu?
entendeu? Lá com a família, ela tinha
dificuldade do sono, intestino preso,
refluxo, eu não tava satisfeito.
E aí eu fui passando alguns remédios,
meopa, teve melhora, mas eu precisava
mais. Após um estudo de um remédio que a
gente começou a usar, esse remédio
homeopata chamado hélio, que a gente
usava para paciente zumbi, ou seja, ela
paciente psiquiátrico internado, tomando
seis remédio de psiquiatro e ele fica
com um zumbi, um casulo, ele não inter
ele não interage com ninguém, ele não
tem troca afetiva. E quando a gente for
estudar essa substância mineral hélio,
ele tá na primeira série da tabela
periódica, a gente vai mostrar isso. E
ele tá completamente isolado. Ele não
troca Antio com ninguém. Falei: "Cara,
se eu posso usar para zumbir, eu posso
usar lá para uma criança que não faz
troca, ela tá isolada do mundo, ela tá
dentro dela, entendeu?" E aí eu comecei
a estudar. Hoje em dia eu atendo muito
paciente psiquiátrico que tá que nem
zubi que poôde ser auxiliado com esse
remédio de homeopata e do que que a
gente pode a gente tá atuando muito com
esse remédio meopata sempre pela
totalidade do caso, mas quando não
melhora com o remédio que eu escolhi eu
vou pro Hélio. Eu tenho muitos casos de
autista com Hélio e tem casos de
Alzheimer também que fica nesse mundo.
Então, é esse remédio prático do que eu
queria mostrar, alguns estudos, alguns
trabalhos científicos lá sobre isso, tá?
Então, vou começar a Ah, esqueci,
esqueci a coisa principal. Esse menino a
gente acompanha há 6 anos. Eu durmo mais
ou menos lá meia-noite, acordo 6 horas
da manhã. Era um dia no consultório, 8
horas da noite, eu tava muito cansado.
Eu cheguei para ele na consulta, era a
última consulta, falei: "Amigo, eu estou
muito cansado, mas quando eu recebo um
abraço e um beijo de amigo, eu tenho
força para atender até 10 horas da
noite, 11 horas da noite, porque a gente
faz um trabalho de CTI, de câncer e tudo
isso." Ele veio três vezes, abraçou, me
deu um beijo, falou: "Obrigado". Quando
ele falou isso, o pai chorou, a mãe
chorou, eu fiquei muito emocionado,
chorei também. Eu entendi a essência que
quando começou comigo aos 3 anos de
idade, as pessoas perguntavam: "O que
que você vai ser quando crescer? Médico,
eu quero ajudar. Eu quero ajudar." Tá?
Então, quando eu recebi um abraço, um
beijo daquele menino autista falando, tá
interagindo melhor eh com os pais, tá
interagindo melhor na escola e tudo,
aquilo aquilo tudo eu entendi a função
de ser médico, tá? Então agora
agora aí eu vou começar aqui, tá?
Muito lindo, muito lindo.
Tá, então vamos compartilhar a tela.
Compartilhar a tela, janela.
Desculpe, é porque eu fiquei emocionado
com as apresentações do Rodrigo, do
Lucas, eu me lembrei desse caso, tá?
Muito bem. Apareceu aí, Alan?
Tá aparecendo,
tá? Então eu, olha só, mas aí, vê se
mudou a tela, por favor, Alan.
Sim, mudou.
Tá, agora tá aparecendo uma criança, um
menino e uma menina.
Isso. Isso.
Tá. Então eu preciso entender como é que
esse ser humano sofre, por que acontece
mais menino do que que menina. A gente
vai dar uns toques aqui, tá? Então,
apresenta-se em eh a incidência média de
três a quatro meninos diagnosticado com
autismo para entender mais uma menina,
tá? Então se calcula 2,4 milhões de
autistas aqui no Brasil, isso equivale a
1,2%
lá da população brasileira, tá? E
o estudo atual é 1 para 31, agora já
baixou para 1,28, entendeu? Mais um para
26.
Alan, eu queria do que você falasse em 2
minutos esse slide do que que você
conseguiu conciliar a integração do
tratamento homeopata com o tratamento
mais ortomolecular. Você pode falar os
dois slides porque eu vi a tua aula e eu
fiquei apaixonado por por esses slides.
Ah, com certeza. Então, eh, uma coisa
que me aproximou muito da homeopatia foi
essa questão do terreno biológico, né,
de você enxergar o ser humano como um
todo. Então, esse slide ele explica de
uma maneira assim bem clara o a minha
filosofia que eu acho que é de de todos
nós aqui que estamos presentes em
relação a essa como usar homeopatia
dentro de uma visão integrativa da
medicina. Então, a homeopatia ela é
muito linda, porque ela é um estudo do
nível da força vital. Ela é uma uma
disciplina, né, que desde o seu começo
ela prezou por entender o ser humano
como um todo. Então, a anamnese
homeopática é muito fascinante porque
ela pergunta aspectos que as outras
anamneses não perguntam sobre a vida
psicosocial do indivíduo, até
espiritual. Então, dentro do
entendimento dos homeopatas e também do
meu, eh, a homeopatia ela se dá a nível
de força vital. Então, a gente atua na
opatia para melhorar o dinamismo, a
força vital do organismo. É uma
intervenção no nível energético,
informacional,
isso vai atuar fortemente num terreno
que tá desequilibrado
e vai facilitar o trabalho que eu já
faço há muitos anos, que é o trabalho de
melhorar a bioquímica desse paciente,
né? Então, quando a gente tem um terreno
biológico totalmente desorganizado, é
muito interessante a gente atuar na
correção das bases bioquímicas com foco
em nutrientes, nas mitocôndrias, na
função mitocondrial, que é muito
importante no microbioma, e dessa
maneira facilitar mais ainda o trabalho
de homeopatia que vai eh cuidar dessa
parte da força vital do nível energético
e informacional dessa pessoa. Então, as
duas disciplinas são muito
complementares. Nós vão trabalhar no
terreno da pessoa e melhorar as
condições de cura desse paciente. Então,
aomolecular dentro da medicina funcional
integrativa, ela prepara o terreno paraa
homeopatia atuar melhor. Elas são eh
complementares e uma não substitui a
outra. Então, a gente usa essa
integração para potencializar a resposta
terapêutica. Então esse slide que vocês
estão vendo aí na tela, né, do piano,
né, é muito interessante. Justamente
você melhora as condições do organismo
para que as duas técnicas possam atuar
em conjunto.
Excelente.
E esse outro slide também é eh fala
sobre isso, fala sobre essa questão da
homeopatia que busca, pelo menos a
homeopatia unicista, né, a ranemaniana,
ela busca um medicamento de base, um
medicamento único que seria mais
apropriado para aquele indivíduo,
pensando como um indivíduo, não da
doença, não estamos tratando doença,
estamos tratando o indivíduo, aí que vem
a repertorização dos milhares e milhares
de remédios homeopáticos para
identificar o padrão individual dessa
pessoa e que possa ter a melhor maior
resposta possível. Então isso tem uma
sinergia eh com a questão do molecular,
que esse medicamento homeopático vai
funcionar melhor com os cofatores
necessários bioquímicos sendo
restaurados. Então, essa questão, eh,
não existe nem protocolo homeopático e
nem protocolo de ortomolecular pro
autismo, porque cada paciente é um
paciente, tem um padrão específico de
disfunções. E isso a gente vai definir
através de uma investigação laboratorial
bem extensa para identificar eh entre os
vários subtipos do autismo, que na
verdade não é uma doença, né? Na verdade
é um termo guarda-chuva para uma
síndrome, como o Dr. Lucas bem disse. E
vários desses pacientes vão ter disbiose
intestinal, vários vão ter intoxicação
ambiental, como foi muito bem dita pro
Dr. Rodrigo Vinc e pelo Dr. Lucas, a
questão da intoxicação pelos metais
pesados e os poluentes orgânicos
persistentes. Vários vão ter disfunção
mitocondrial, tanto genética quanto
epigenética, quanto ligada as
intoxicações que foram faladas. e vários
vão ter também comprometimento de
metilação, que é também assunto de uma
aula que eu eu dei recentemente aí pro
nosso grupo avançado de homeopatia.
Pode continuar com Luiz, depois eu falo
mais. É, olha só, mas eu acho que eh ela
Deus te deu uma luz para fazer um resumo
de tudo do que que a gente quer fazer
daqui paraa frente. A integração do
tratamento homeopata pra gente ela
preparar o terreno de uma forma química.
a bioquímica, entendeu? Então, por isso
do do que que do que que a gente tá
conversando, eu, Rodrigo, Lucas e Alan,
eu acho que esse momento lá das nossas
vidas é pra gente poder passar isso para
as pessoas. A gente tá falando sobre
autismo, mas a gente pode conversar de
uma forma diferente para qualquer tipo
de doença, entendeu, Alan? Então eu eu
acho do que que foi muito feliz com isso
e é isso do que que eu quero
daqui paraa frente lá tentar passar
minha experiência os últimos 43 anos de
clínica, tá?
Olha só,
homeopatia existe há 230 anos. E por que
que as pessoas atualmente elas estão
procurando homeopatia? Tá por causa do
limite do tratamento alopata, os quadros
de evolução lenta, mais arrastada. passa
o custo preventivo, não tem fitos
colaterais, é seguro, entendeu? Então,
eh, tudo tem alcance e tudo tem um certo
limite. A gente vai aproveitar o alcance
do tratamento homeopato, esse limite
para integrar com as outras formas para
tatar o ser humano como um todo, tá?
Então
isso aqui, isso aqui já foi falado. Ou
seja, o tratamento homeopato, o que que
a gente vê na prática clínica é ele
espaça mais as infecções. A gente vê que
que as crianças do autismo estão tomando
muito antibiótico, ela muito corticoide,
após o tratamento homeopata, eh sente
que espaça mais as doenças, tá? Eh,
principalmente intestino mais preso,
refluxo, diarreia, distúrbo de sono,
ansiedade, entendeu? Ficando mais
irritável. Então, a gente vê que as mães
falam: "Ó, após esse remédio tá dormindo
melhor, ele tá mais interagindo com ele
mesmo, ele tá interagindo, as próprias
professoras estão falando isso, é isso
que a gente quer escutar. Então, como a
gente grava casos, infelizmente aqui eu
não posso mostrar casos gravados pela
questão do código médico, mas a gente vê
a criança quando começou com 2 anos o
tratamento homeopata, após o tratamento
homeopata, eh, uns anos, a criança
interagindo, falando,
abraçando, dando um beijo, falando mais
obrigado. É isso do que que a gente quer
fazer, tá? É isso do que que a gente tá
tentando. Então, para isso, eu preciso
ver como foi gerado essa criança, a
história de vida dessa mãe, a história
de vida desse pai. Tem vários trabalhos
que pais mais velhos, espermatozoides
mais velhos tem tendência eh um estudo
na Índia que mostra que pais mais
velhos, que espermatozóides mais velhos,
tem que ter, eh tiveram crianças eh que
desenvolveram autismo por causa disso.
Então, a gente entra primeiro na
história de vida da mãe, como foi
gerada, como é que tava essa mãe, se
teve algum trauma ou não. Então, é uma
coisa mais profunda, tá? Então eu
preciso conhecer a natureza de ser d
esse ser humano, a personalidade, seus
medos. Então é a técnica em termos
homeopata, individualizar esse ser
humano a totalidade de desses sintomas.
Um aspecto atualmente que me ajuda muito
em casos de CTI e de câncer, pessoas em
coma e até no autismo, o tipo de língua
dela, o tipo de pulso dela, o tipo de
olho dela, o tipo da pupila dela,
entendeu? Então são coisas que faz parte
da consulta homeopata que faz que faz a
diferença para mim muito em caso de
autismo, de CTI, de câncer, Alzheimer,
Paxon, tem me ajudado muito, tá? Eu
preciso saber como esse ser humano tá
sendo sugado. A força vital do que ele
falou, o Alan, tá? Eu preciso entender
esse lado autodestrutivo que existe
dentro do ser humano, eh, do que que
produz as células ruins, pensamentos
ruins, medos, ansiedades, mágoas,
ressentimento, afeta nosso corpo e nossa
mente. Eu preciso estimular um lado que
produz células boas, pensamentos bons,
que é a parte divina pra gente fazer a
nossa função, o propósito assim de vida.
Atualmente são 8.500 00 remédios
homeopata, tanto do reino mineral,
bactérias, eh algas, fungo, plantas,
animais, tá? Eu preciso, o ser humano,
ele me fala suas características, ele me
fala o nome do remédio. Eu que tenho que
ter estudado os últimos 43 anos, eu
preciso conhecer tudo isso e a pista
para me chegar naquele remédio aqui. É o
seguinte, ou toca ou não toca. Se se não
tiver passando das doenças físicas,
infecções, se aquela criança autista não
tiver melhorando o sono, se não tiver
estimulando a função intestinal dele e
tudo, se ele não tiver interagindo
melhor com ele, melhor com as outras
crianças, eu tenho certeza que o remédio
que eu escolhi entre os 8.500 remédios,
aquela criança a aquela criança não foi
sensível, tá? Então, é um trabalho
árduo, é uma é uma dedicação, um estudo
muito profundo.
Ou seja, eh, no próprio Google Acadêmico
tem 1180 trabalhos, ou seja, os cursos
que a gente dá, a gente vai trabalho por
trabalho, evolução benefício do
tratamento homeopata ou não, tá? Então,
só vou mostrando isso aqui, outras
pesquisas, tá? Como, como lá já foi
falado isso, eu vou pular por causa da
hora um pouquinho, tá? Eu não vou falar
sobre vários trabalhos, principalmente
na Índia, que mostraram que crianças que
fazem o tratamento clássico também
individualizado, tá? Mostraram que essa
criança ficou melhor na sociedade
convencional, tá? Então, é um estudo
muito interessante.
Eu vou pular para poder entrar o Alan e
ele vai falar do nível um, nível dois e
nível três. E ele vai dar uma pincelada.
Rodrigo também, o Lucas também vai falar
depois, porque eu queria entrar numa
coisa, existe 200 remédios homeopata
para autismo do do que que a gente tem
experiência, barita carbônica, buforana,
anacáo, hélio, que eu amo, tá? Então, a
gente tem casos clínicos que foi ajudado
com um remédio diferente, porque a
consulta homeopata é individualizante.
A gente eh trata daquele ser humano e
não somente do autismo. A gente trata da
pessoa que tem autismo que vai receber
um remédio diferente. Quando eu não
consigo ajudar com esse remédio
diferente, eu tento esse remédio hélio,
porque eu tenho tido muitos casos
interessantes com ele, tá? Então,
eu
achei muito interessante essa frase do
Adib Jatene. Quando o médico não pode
curar, ele precisa aliviar. Quando não
pode curar nem aliviar, precisa
confortar. O médico precisa ser
especialista em gente. A consulta
homeopata
ortomolecular integrativa, a gente é
especialista em gente e ser humano, tá?
Então, eu queria falar de um estudo que
a gente faz profundo, que nos cursos a
gente aprofunda bastante, é o estudo da
tabela periódica. Eu não suportava
química, só tirava nota baixa em
química, era horrível química e tudo.
Hoje eu estudo cada substância dessa a
mais profundidade. E hélio é uma
substância mineral completamente
isolada. Ele não troca gás, ele ele é um
gás nobre, não troca ânil cátio com
ninguém. Foi por isso que a gente foi
usar em doenças psiquiátricas,
Alzheimer, Parkson, tá? Então ele, eu só
vou aumentar um pouquinho aqui para
vocês verem aqui um pouquinho.
O Hélio é usado muito para autismo, tá?
E a característica dele, do que que a
gente usa, eh, tem a ver com a
concepção,
eh, a questão de existência, eu sou, não
sou, tá? Energia, como se fosse um bebê
sem corpo, consciência, tá? Então,
esse é um estudo, esse é um pequeno
resumo de Hélio, o tema existência, a
concepção, existe ou não existo, sou ou
não sou, tá? Eh, então essa essa é a
substância do que que a gente estuda.
Isso é como a gente estuda, tá? A
palavra hélio é a forma, tá? É um gás em
odoro, incolor, não reage com nenhum
outro elemento. Então a gente foi pra
clínica, pra parte teórica, interagir
nisso tudo. É um jogo do que que a gente
faz, a substância, tá? Então,
o o hélio eh eles estão como aterrizando
no topo da montanha, eles não estão
ainda conectados um pouco mais para lá
do que aqui, tá? A sensação, o paciente
hélio flutua, mas não conecta ao mundo.
Essa sensação. Então, é esse link que a
gente faz com autismo, é esse link que a
gente faz com as pessoas que estão num
casulo fechada com cinco, seis remédios
psiquiatra, o Alzheimic, ele tá fechado
naquele mundo dele, tá? Então, foi esse
estudo do que que me fez estudar, ficar
mais profundo com essa substância.
Tá,
gente, por causa da hora eu vou ter que
dar uma pulada em algumas coisas aqui,
porque não dá. Eu tenho pelo menos 500
powerp, eu não vou conseguir falar
todos, mas eu vou dar uma,
seja, a fase do feto não precisa fazer
nada, flutua no líquido aminiótico, sem
quaisquer preocupações, sem esforço, tá?
Ah, na característica como dorme, tá?
São as crianças que se cortam, mutila
seu corpo. Tem tem várias crianças
autistas que faziam isso, tá? Aversão a
companhia, né?
Vamos lá. Então, a sensação como se
tivesse ela flutuando, leveza. é o
grande tema de hélio associado aos
sintomas físicos, tá? Então eu só vou
passar para um caso clínico agora para
não estender mais porque
por causa por causa desse horário, tá?
Parece que Hélio vê de fora de cima, tá?
Ele não entrou nesse mundo ainda.
Ou seja, a gente vai ver um caso clínico
primeiro. Olha só, após a vacinação
contra hepatite B, mas uma mãe trouxe
seu bebê de 2 meses, afirmando que ele
estava fazendo muito pouco contato
visual e que e que ele que ele não
respondia a voz dela. Outras vezes ela
encontrava sorrindo para uma parede
próxima, mas não em em relação ao
contato com os outros ao seu redor. A
mãe descreveu que seu filho não gostava
que seus braços estivessem amarrados.
Eh, ou seja, a gente prescreveu
primeiro, entendeu? Mais hidrogênio M.
Eh, teve mais uma melhora por duas
semanas após os sintomas começaram a
retornar. Outra dose de 1 M a gente
prescreveu, não teve muita melhora,
depois 10 M. E após a gente mudar, ou
seja, aqui é o seguinte, a gente passa
um remédio, se não tiver melhorando, a
gente sobe a dosagem, se não tiver
melhorando, a gente troca de remédio. A
gente trocou para Hélio, fez com que um
bebê emergisse rapidamente de seu estado
desconectado em alguns dias. A partir
daí, ele começou a ultrapassar marcos
normais na infância, não necessitando
mais de doses, tá? Então,
um outro paciente, eu vou eu só vou ver
um caso um pouquinho mais curto aqui,
tá? Olha
só, eh, além de casos autistas, o Hélio
poderia ser considerado em pacientes
nascidos de cesariana eletiva, ou seja,
casos que a decisão de fazer uma
cesariana foi tomada enquanto as dores
do parto ainda não havia começado e o
feto ainda estava e em muito bom estado.
Nesse caso, o fato, o feto é retirado do
útero sem sofrer dores de parto ou sem
qualquer perigo pra sua vida, tá?
Então aqui é um estudo de hélio em
demência, síndrome de
hospitalização, tá? Então, é um estudo
do de um médico holandês Schen, que ele
tem muitos casos de autismo de hélio e
síndromes hospitalares. Foi foi esse
estudo. Estudei muito esse médico
holandês, tá? Então aqui são são vários
remédios homeopata com casos clínicos do
que a gente passou um remédio para
autismo, né, com perfil essencial,
pontos chaves, carcinosino, barita,
agárrico, elébros, buforana, tuia,
licopódio,
extramônio. E como a gente estuda os
remédios, né? a gente vê eh ação do
remédio, sintomas mentais, as sensações,
a localizações. É um mapa que a gente
faz do remédio paraa gente estudar
quando o paciente tiver falando as
características do autismo, ou seja, as
queixas do paciente do lado esquerdo e
esse aqui do lado direito casa, tá?
Então é um mapa de vários remédios
homeopatas, tá? e com a as
características de como a gente estuda.
Então, a gente tem casos clínicos de
vários remédios homeopatas, tá? E com o
estudo deles, o diagnóstico de
diferencial do que que a gente mostra
nos cursos e casos curtos de autismo,
né? Com insônia ficando rigidez, 6 anos
de autismo, tá?
O medo da mudança, pouco contato visual,
crises alterar a rotina. Carinhoso após
esse remédio aqui, lacenosino, o sono
melhorado, as crises melhoraram em 50%,
tá? Então temos outro remédio, 4 anos,
olhar fixos, os movimentos repetitivos,
eléboros e após o remédio melhora na
progressiva, aumento do contato, tá? E
outros casos, ó, só para terminar, isso
aqui é um adolescente cuteia mais
agressivo, pividade, 15 anos, agitação,
automutilação. Com esse remédio meopa,
as crises eh eh lá diminuíram bastante,
tá? Então seria isso, tá?
Esse é o nosso contato. Se por acaso eh
é alguém que quiser tirar uma dúvida,
entrar em contato ou qualquer coisa, tá?
Eu queria, esse é o nosso site
explicando o tratamento. Eu queria
agradecer a Deus o presente, a minha
esposa, a minha família, tá? e a chegada
dos meu neto gêmeos em São Paulo. Queria
agradecer a Deus, homeopatia, a família
lá por tudo isso, tá? Obrigado, Alan.
Eh, obrigado, Rodrigo, obrigado, Lucas,
por participar desse projeto nosso de
estudar vários remédios de diferentes,
eh, com enfoque diferente, entendeu? Mas
abordagem diferente e que para tentar o
ser humano encontrar o seu caminho com
menos sofrimento no corpo, na mente e no
espírito. Tá?
Obrigado.
Maravilha. Muito bom.
Muito obrigado pela sua apresentação.
Também aproveitando a oportunidade para
agradecer o Dr. Lucas e o Dr. Rodrigo e
eu vou fazer uma apresentação bem
rápida, bem objetiva, tá? Eu tenho uma
apresentação aqui sobre a parte
bioquímica, sobre a parte de disbiose
intestinal. disfunção mitocondrial e
também a parte de problemas neurológicos
específicos. Mas eu vou entrar dentro da
parte agora do tratamento para a gente
não se estender demais.
Pera aí. Pronto.
Bem, pessoal, primeira coisa que eu
queria falar para vocês, além daquele
daquela questão que nós estávamos
falando sobre
a integração, né, do das técnicas
automularis da medicina funcional
integrativa com a questão da homeopatia.
Eu queria falar para vocês sobre a falta
dos estudos a nível assim de estudos
multicêntricos, eh estudos umbrella, em
relação a uma intervenção específica que
seja altamente eficaz pros sintomas
centrais do autismo. E eu vou explicar
para vocês porque que eu acho que isso
acontece. Então vamos começar falando da
revisão Umbrella da Nature, que é uma
revisão guarda-chuva que junta várias
outras metanálises. E ela analisou então
justamente essa eficácia das
intervenções no autismo nos sintomas
centrais, como se fosse uma intervenção
para fins, digamos assim, curativos.
Então, a gente sabe que autismo não tem
cura, mas eh essa esse estudo da Nature
foi em cima dos tratamentos que poderiam
de fato intervir nos sintomas principais
do autismo e não simplesmente os
remédios que se usam hoje em dia dentro
da medicina mais ortodoxas, que é só
para acalmar o autista que tá agitado.
Então essa revisão ela não encontrou
evidências robustas para nenhum remédio
isolado. Mas isso, na verdade, que que
isso reflete? Que que significa?
fala sobre a limitação dos ensaios
tradicionais que tem o quê? Alto ruído e
baixa resolução. Já vou explicar para
vocês o que que significa isso. Isso
acontece. Então esse alto ruído, ele
dilui a individualidade na média
estatística. Então para vocês entenderem
com um exemplo muito prático do que eu
tô falando, vamos falar aqui de uma
situação hipotética, tá? Não é um estudo
real, é uma situação hipotética para
vocês entenderem, tá? Quase uma
parábola. Se nós falamos, por exemplo,
de 2000 pacientes que têm o diagnóstico
de tetra torno de espectro autista, eles
vão ter aí pelo menos 20 subtipos
fisiopatológicos distintos nessa
população, OK? E cada subtipo nessa
população de 2000 pacientes vai querer
dizer nesse estudo hipotético 100
pessoas, 100 pacientes. Então, se a
gente for estudar um determinado
remédio, um tratamento, vamos dizer, por
exemplo, a leucovorina, né? o ácido
forínico, que ele funciona por um
subtipo, que é o subtipo com a
deficiência cerebral de receptores
parafolato, que tem os autoanticorpos
contra o receptor. E supondo que esse
tratamento tenha 80% de eficácia nesse
subgrupo específico, qual que seria o
cálculo, né? Subgrupo alvo de 100
pacientes que tem essa alteração aí do
receptor, 80 responderiam positivamente
a esse remédio. Seria uma taxa altíssima
de 80% de resposta, certo? Porém, nos
outros 100 pacientes dos outros
subtipos, praticamente nenhum
responderia, porque o mecanismo de ação
não se aplicaria a eles. Se a gente
fosse analisar, então, de modo geral, os
2000 pacientes, a taxa de resposta
global nesse estudo seria 80 respostas
para 2.000 pacientes, que seria somente
4%. Então, qualquer agência regulatória,
qualquer comitê de revisão olharia para
esses números, resultado de 4% e dizia e
diria, né, que esse tratamento seria
clinicamente relevante. Então, a
publicação provavelmente desse estudo
diria que não teria nenhuma evidência de
eficácia, mas a realidade é que existe
um subgrupo de 100 pacientes pros quais
o tratamento tem 80% de eficácia, o que
seria extraordinário. Então, essa
diferença entre os 4% e os 80% não é
falha de tratamento, é uma falha do
desenho do estudo em reconhecer a
heterogeneidade da condição. Isso
acontece com o autismo e isso acontece
também com o Alzheimer, porque são
doenças heterogêneas que são múltiplas
causas pro mesmo problema. No caso do
autismo, é pior ainda, porque você tem
aí eh uma heterogeneidade maior ainda
que no Alzheimer. Então, é por isso que
sob a ótica da biologia de sistemas, que
para mim é uma coisa que eu tô cada vez
mais apaixonado por esse tema, e da
medicina P4, que é medicina
personalizada,
a realidade é outra. A gente tem que
utilizar cada vez mais informação, nuvem
de dados denso, que seria o conjunto de
dados genômicos, metabolômicos,
microbiômicos e clínicos. Eu sei que
isso aí torna talvez muito mais caro
essa avaliação, mas para quem tem
condições, o ideal é você juntar o
máximo possível de informações para
entender a rede biológica única de cada
paciente. Isso também o que me deixa
fascinado com a homeopatia, porque a
homeopatia enxerga o indivíduo e analisa
não tão não tanto esses dados
bioquímicos, mas os dados gerais desse
paciente para ter um remédio específico
para aquele indivíduo e não para aquela
doença. Aí nós saímos da generalização,
que é a grande armadilha da medicina
cartesiana ou da ciência cartesiana, e
nós entramos na medicina de precisão,
né? Então, é por isso que na prática
clínica, ao tratar as disfunções
específicas de cada organismo, nós temos
que
verificar individualmente isso daí,
observar respostas significativas e
seguras que os grandes estudos não
conseguem ter por causa desse excesso de
ruído, porque é uma quantidade muito
grande de pessoas diferentes que a gente
tenta estudar um remédio só e não vai
funcionar para todo mundo. Por isso que
a gente tem que estudar cada indivíduo
da maneira mais específica possível.
Então vamos falar aqui dos tratamentos
que eu considero os mais importantes
dentro do dorto molecular pro autismo.
Começando pelo básico, é que a correção
de de deficiências vitamínicas. A
vitamina D de dado é muito importante.
Vitamina D tem muito a ver com o sistema
nervoso central com sistema imune. Então
o nosso alvo é manter os níveis dessa
vitamina D entre 50 e 80, sempre com a
vitamina K2 associada para direcionar o
cálcio pro lugar certo e não aumentar a
calcificação de partes moles ou de
artérias. Teve um estudo agora
recentíssimo do ano passado usando
vitamina D em doses eh de 300 unidades
por kilo por dia, que mostrou redução de
marcadores inflamatórios nos autistas e
melhora comportamental. E pro suporte a
metilação, utilizar o ácido folínico,
porque a gente sabe que até 75% dos
autistas têm essa alteração do receptor.
Eu falei naquele naquela comparação que
era 20%, mas só para eh para fins de
comparação para vocês entenderem a
lógica que eu tava utilizando. Mas no
mundo real, essa alteração do receptor
aí do do ácido do do folato é na faixa
de 75%.
Então, para suporte da metilação, você
vai usar o ácido polínico e não ácido
fólico, nem metifolato, porque é a
substância que vai passar por cima do
problema do receptor, do dos anticorpos
contra o receptor. E você vai utilizar
na dose 05, 5 a 2 mg por kg dia, tá? Em
duas tomadas. Então, em crianças que t
esses anticorpos antirceptor de folato,
a resposta vai ser melhor ainda, que a
maioria. E a metucobalamina na formativa
de 1 a 2 mg por dia ou 1000 a 2000
microg por dia, é de preferência na
forma sublingual ou na forma injetável
quando for necessário. E pra função
mitocondrial nós temos que muitas cham
pessoas chamam de coquetel ou de
quarteto fantástico. a gente utiliza a
alcarnitina, que ela transporta as
gorduras, os ácidos grassos para dentro
da mitocôndria, pra mitocôndria poder
queimar esse ácido grasso na forma de
energia, aumentar essa eficiência
energética. Então, nessa dose de 30 a 50
mg por kg por dia, a coisema que é 10 na
forma de biquinol, 100 a 200 mg por dia.
Lembrando, pessoal, que essas doses aqui
você tem que conversar com o seu médico,
se você não for da área de saúde. Isso
aqui não é tratamento, é só eh
informação científica. Você tem que
sempre conversar com o seu médico ou
médica ou nutricionista. para validar
essas doses e o ácido alfalipúrico, 200,
600 mg por dia, que funciona como um
antioxidante e um cofator enzimático.
Então, tem um estudo duplo cego com essa
combinação que mostrou uma melhora
significativa em marcadores de função
mitocondrial e num comportamento
e um tamanho de efeito considerado
grande. Pro intestino, os probióticos
são muito importantes. Então, as cepas
mais estudadas inclui o lactobacilos
aminosos GG, o bífitto bactério infantes
e o lactobacilos Reutere. A dose pode
variar de 10 a 50 bilhões de
unidadesfumadoras de colônia por dia.
Introdução gradual para minimizar
reações. Alguns autistas podem ter
reações, especialmente gases, extensão
abdominal, de conforto no começo do
tratamento. Utilizar prebióticos são as
fibras alimentares. Aí tem várias, né?
Tem a fibra da casa, que eu gosto muito.
Tem também o gos, que é o
galactoossacarídeos,
que vão alimentar essas bactérias do bem
do intestino. E a suplementação
combutirato, né, que é muito
interessante. O butirato tem uma ação
super interessante, já falei isso em
vários vídeos no meu canal, de 300 até
900 mg por dia, que aí a faixa de dose
média 300, 600 mg. E isso é muito
interessante para melhorar a saúde
intestinal, melhorar a barreira
intestinal e reduzir a questão da
translocação bacteriana. E uma
intervenção que tem ganhado bastante
destaque é uso suforando. Suforafando,
ele é extraído dos brotos dos vegetais
crucíferos, dos brotos de brócolis. Teve
uma metanálise de 2025 que teve seis
estudos e 333 participantes e que houve
uma melhora significativa da interação
social. Esse autista passou a ter mais
interação utilizando sufor. E qual que é
o mecanismo? Ele ativa um sistema
chamado NRF2,
que é o maestro das defesas
antioxidantes do organismo. Então ele
vai ligar centenas de genes de proteção
celular de forma simultânea. A dose vai
ser em torno de 1 a 2 micromoles por
kilo por dia. Tem várias preparações
padronizadas aí no mercado. Temos o
famoso NC, né? é uma enetilcisteína, que
é o precursor principal da gluta
junto aí com a glicina e com glutâmico.
Só que esse aqui que é o aminoácido mais
determinante aí que é o mais inimitante
na formação da gluta então usando o NAC
na dose de 600 a 1800 mg por dia, isso
vai ter um efeito na redução de
irritabilidade de alguns eh de vários
autistas que foi verificado em vários
estudos. Então, crianças com autismo
consistentemente
tem a glutationa reduzida, é um dos
problemas do autista, que é a redução da
proteção antioxidante, aumento do
estresse oxidativo, utilizando o NAC e
em muitos casos também a glicina, você
vai conseguir corrigir essa questão do
estresse oxidativo. e pro distúbio de
sono. Esse é um assunto um pouquinho
mais polêmico que ah tem estudos aí
favoráveis e desfavoráveis à melatonina,
mas para autista eu acho que a parte
positiva predomina porque é um distúo de
sono é muito comum nesse grupo, afeta
até 80% das crianças com teia. A
melatonina pode ser usada começando
doses baixas, 05 mg e subindo aos
pouquinhos, mas pode chegar até 6 mg por
dia, administrada pouco antes do sono. E
a melatonina não é só um indutor de
sono. Na verdade, isso aí é a parte
menos importante, porque a melatonina
ela é sintetizada as mitocôndrias, ela
funcionam como um potente antioxidante
do ambiente mitocondrial. Então a gente
usa muito mais como antioxidante do que
propriamente o indutor do sono. E tem
também uma conexão muito interessante,
elegante entre o ritmo cicadiano e a
função mitocondrial. O ômega-3 também
muito importante, especialmente o EPA na
dose de 1 a 2 g por dia, que vai
contribuir paraa modulação inflamatória.
O zinco na dose de 10 a 30 mg por dia, o
magnésio de 6 a 10 mg por kg por dia,
nas somas sempre queadas, né, que são
absorvidas mais facilmente. São todos
cofatores aí de centenas de enzimas
importantes que frequentemente estão
reduzidos nos autistas.
Agora eu queria falar só de um caso
clínico para mostrar como é que essa
abordagem funciona na prática. Um menino
de 5 anos com diagnóstico TEA moderado,
né, TEA grau dois de suporte e que foi
diagnosticado aos 3 anos, que tinha como
queixes principais constipação crônica,
distúbro de sono, seletividade alimentar
extrema e cri frequências de
irritabilidade.
E estava em uso de risperidona, que é um
dos remédios aí que são aprovados para
tratamento do TEA, mas não é para
sintomas centrais, é para reduzir
simplesmente a ritabilidade da criança.
E esse remédio tem como efeito colateral
muito importante o ganho de peso. Então
essa criança tava ficando obesa e a
família buscava alternativas. E na
investigação nós percebemos que a
vitamina D tava super baixa. A nossa
meta é ficar entre 60 e 80. Essa criança
tinha 18. A ferritina muito baixa também
muito comum no autista. Inclusive o meu
filho que é portador da síndrome tem uma
tendência ferritina muito baixa. Então
essa criança tinha a ferritina de 15.
Isso é bem comum, tem que ser observado,
tem que tem que eh melhorar essa
reposição do ferro nessas crianças. O
zinco também tava no limite e essa
criança pôde fazer o teste de orgânicos
e mostrou marcadores aí debiose com
aumento de marcadores característicos do
costrídium, que é uma bactéria aí eh que
é muito frequente tá aumentada nessas
crianças com disbiose e autismo. E essa
criança conseguiu fazer também o exame
que vai pro exterior dos anticorpos
antreceptor de folato e vieram
positivos.
Então, vejam como cada achado nos guiou
para uma intervenção. Veja como essa
intervenção tem que ser altamente
personalizada. Nós iniciamos vitamina D,
4000 unidades por kg, eh, com K2
associado, ferro queelado 15 mg por dia,
zinco, 15 mg por dia, probiótico
específico para disbiose identificada, o
ácido folínico miligr por kilo por dia e
por causa da questão dos anticorpos e a
medicobalamina também para dar suporte à
metilação. E a evolução em três meses
foi altamente gratificante com resolução
da constipação, melhora do sono, mais
com intividade, iniciativa de interação
melhor, redução importante da
ritabilidade dessa criança e a criança
foi gradualmente reduzindo a dose da
respiridona e a família após várias
semanas de tratamento relatou que a
criança era outra, tá? Então quer dizer
o quê? Quer dizer que ela curou do
autismo? Não, pessoal, não é isso que eu
estamos falando aqui. Nós estamos
falando de tratamentos individualizados
paraa melhora desses pacientes sem
prometer nenhuma cura. Não é essa a
situação que nós estamos abordando aqui.
Outro caso ilustrativo, uma menina de 8
anos de idade, nós sabemos que autismo
em meninas é bem menos comum, mas quando
acontece às vezes é mais grave. Ela é,
mas nesse caso era um té nível um, era
nível de cuidados menores, uma queixa
principal de fadiga desproporcional,
tinha muito cansaço. Os pais diziam que
ela não tinha energia para nada. Ela
tinha uma hipotonia que é muito comum em
autista, né, que aquela falta de tôus
muscular, ela teve uma regressão de
habilidades motoras finas após um
episódio febril com ano de idade e a
neurologia e a neuropediatria tinham
descartado outras causas. A investigação
mostrou a vitamina D também abaixo do
ideal 22, a B12 também baixa em 280
e que o laboratório considera normal,
mas a gente quer manter acima de 600. Os
orgânicos urinários também mostraram
marcadores claros de disfunção
mitocondrial, tinha aumento do lactato e
a desproporção, né, com aumento do
lactato muito maior do que o do piruvato
e a carnitina também estava baixa nesse
estudo aí de metabolômica.
Então o protocolo focou na mitocôndria
com elarnitina iniciada com 50 mg por
kg, biquinol 100 mg duas vezes ao dia,
affolipuo
200 mg duas vezes ao dia, a riboflavina
que é a B2, a tiamina para como
cofatores aí também da metilação.
Corrigimos a vitamina D, corrigimos
também a B12 para chegar a níveis
adequados.
E oito semanas a criança começou a
tolerar atividades físicas que antes
deixava ela exaurida e aos três meses
houve recuperação das habilidades
motoras finas perdidas e a professora
relatou aumentou o significativo de
tempo de atenção. O controle
laboratorial mostrou na molização dos
marcadores e ela teve então essa melhora
importante da da falta de energia. Isso
ajudou bastante no diagnóstico,
direcionando esse tratamento para a
restauração da função mitocondrial.
Então vou falar aqui, isso aqui eu vou
pular que são estudos clínicos que estão
em andamento sobre a questão aí de
estudo mitocondrial,
a questão de uso de probióticos e também
das dietas low fod map. Isso aqui são
estudos que estão em andamento, até que
isso aqui é mais apropriado por uma
apresentação para um público mais
especializado.
Então,
eh falando aí sobre considerações
práticas,
então vamos encerrar esse assunto
falando que a ordem de introdução
importa. Comece pelo básico, que é
correção de deficiências nutricionais, o
suporte intestinal com probiótico,
regulação do sono com a melatonina, faça
avaliação homeopática para fazer o
tratamento conjunto. Depois, se
necessário, pode avançar para
intervenções mais específicas a partir
de exames mais eh especializados, mais
eh como é o caso dos estudos
metabolômicos de ácidos orgânicos
urinários ou até aquele eh estudo dos
anticorpos anticreceptor de folato, né?
Então é importante introduzir uma
intervenção de cada vez a cada duas ou
três semanas ou quatro semanas para
poder avaliar a resposta individual de
cada um desses suplementos e poder estar
entendendo melhor o que que tá tendo
mais resultado, tá? E é muito importante
documentar, usar escalas e validadas,
escala ABC, escala CARS, eh antes e e
depois repetir os exames laboratoriais.
Então é muito importante saber se tá no
caminho certo desse paciente
e tem que manter expectativas realistas,
pessoal. Não estamos aqui propondo de
forma alguma ninguém falou em falar,
ninguém falou aqui em curar o autismo.
Nós estamos propondo otimizar o terreno
biológico para cada criança possa
expressar o seu melhor potencial, seu
máximo potencial. E algumas crianças vão
responder de maneira rápida e dramática,
outras vão ter melhoras mais lentas e
mais demoradas. E a variabilidade é
muito grande, porque o espectro é muito
heterogêneo, tá? Eu acredito são mais de
20 doenças que estão aí eh debaixo desse
guarda-chuva do diagnóstico do TEA. E
lembrar que essas intervenções são
complementares, tanto molecular quanto
homeopatia, quanto as terapias
comportamentais. É muito importante a
terapia comportamental. Aqui a Dra.
Luciana Perrude entrou na live, não sei
se ela tá indo aí, que é uma excelente
terapeuta ocupacional. Muito importante
a fono, audiologia, isso tudo são
fundamentais, são super importantes. O
meu filho fez tudo isso, fez o fono, fez
terapia ocupacional, fez terapia
psicológica, fez aba, então a gente tem
que juntar todos os tipos de tratamento
e o que nós fazemos como médicos é criar
um substrato biológico mais favorável
para que essas terapias eh funcionem
melhor. Então, era isso que eu queria
falar para vocês, para a gente não
estender demais no tempo aqui.
Posso só dar os parabéns? Fiquei
impressionado,
Dr. Lucas, parabéns. Fiquei, olha,
impressionado com a sua, com a sua aula.
E veio um monte de coisa aqui que eu
queria acrescentar e também com seus
casos, Dr. Luiz, que incríveis.
Parabéns. E o Dr. Alan já conheço há
muito tempo, sou paciente do Dr. Alan
também, queria dar os parabéns e sempre
super didático, né? E eu queria só então
acrescentar que essa parte de de
bisfenol que o Dr. Lucas falou, ele a
grande parte das resinas que vão na
boca, elas têm o bisfenol. Então 99% das
resinas tem o bisfenol. Que a gente
precisa ficar atento e procurar
dentistas que não coloquem flur na boca
das crianças, assim como também não
coloquem resinas que liberem benol, né?
Claro que tem muito mais coisa aqui que
eu anotei de cada um, mas eu queria
fazer um convite. Como a gente vai ter
mais uma live do CIS, né? Fiquem atento
às nossas mídias, né? Eu não coloquei
aqui a a minha, mas eh DR Rodrigo 25,
tá? Então
assim como também Dr., né, Dra. Alan, de
vocês todos o convite prociso, mas
acompanha a gente aí.
E queria só agradecer a vocês, não vou
mais me estender, não.
Muita gratidão pelo convite e por estar
aqui com vocês. Mas eu queria dar os
parabéns eh para todos e queria deixar
uma mensagem aqui, é que eh
Obrigado.
A nossa função esse momento de vida é
a tentar ajudar a esse grupo de famílias
que sofre muito com essa situação. que a
gente queria tentar estimular com
exemplos bons, né? Então eu aí queria
fazer uma pergunta pros três agora.
Se por acaso, se alguém da família de
vocês, infelizmente, tivesse um
diagnóstico com alguma criança autisma,
o que que vocês surgiriem eh falassem eh
falar eh falariam para essa pessoa da
sua família e tudo além da ajuda bucal
odontológica,
o o estudo, entendeu, mais ortomolecular
integrativo, tá? as próprias terapias, o
que que cada um sugeria eh com o estudo
de vocês, a experiência de de vocês na
clínica e tudo, do que que você ia falar
para uma pessoa da sua família, Rodrigo,
por favor, começar contigo. Uma outra
coisa que eu queria falar pro Dr. Alan,
que a gente talvez não possa curar, mas
a gente pode prevenir, né? Então, a
prevenção é o melhor caminho de tudo.
Prevenção para tudo é o melhor caminho,
porque a integrativa é ótima, mas se a
gente conseguir prevenir é muito melhor.
Então, prevenir a hora que for remover
os amálgamas, precisa procurar alguém
que saiba fazer, porque na verdade o
grande risco é na no naquele efeito que
a gente tem de vibração, que é a
ressonância do mercúrio no corpo todo,
que acaba liberando e aí acaba
sobrecarregando, né, a toda o nosso
fígado, rins, etc. Então, precisa tem
ter uma técnica para ser feita essa
remoção segura. H,
toda essa parte de mercúrio também,
tanto da alimentação como também outras
formas que existem, né, de contaminação
com Mercúrio devem ser evitadas.
Procurar profissionais competentes,
assim como você, Dr. Luí, Dr. Lucas, Dr.
Alan, que possa est orientando, né? Mas
depois para mim é muito o que o Dr.
Lucas falou, temos que trabalhar terreno
biológico, temos trabalhar a saúde
intestinal, temos que trabalhar focos
inflamatórios que estão dentro do
intestino, estão também na boca. A boca
tem diversos focos inflamatórios que vai
desde a gengivite, perodontite, dentro
dos canais, dentro do osso, na cade, né?
né? Então você tem uma série de coisas
que podem acabar interferindo e e
piorando todo esse processo inflamatório
que é neurotóxico, né, e que vai ativar
o sistema de luta. Então, falaria
principalmente para procurar um
tratamento integrativo, entendendo que
tem a parte da estrutura, a parte da
emoção, a parte bioquímica, a parte
biofísica e também tem a parte
espiritual, né, que não vamos entrar
nesse momento aqui, mas tá tudo ligado à
espiritualidade. A gente precisa
procurar com vocês que entendem isso,
hein? Hein, Rodrigo, a gente não pode
separar o corpo da mente e do espírito,
né? Então eu acho que a gente tem que
ver tudo. Lucas, o que que você com a
com a tua experiência que você atende
muito autismo, tem uma experiência, é
uma pessoa que dá cursos do que que você
é convidado para congresso mundial,
congresso brasileiro e tudo e ainda
corre a 42 km eh por semana
ainda toca bateria, Rodrigo Alan,
entendeu?
Olha que legal. Parabéns. O que que você
poderia dar um estímulo para as pessoas?
Que caminho mais saudável assim, Lucas?
Luiz, eh, obrigado pela pergunta e Dr.
Alan, parabéns pela pela sua palestra.
Você tem uma capacidade de síntese
incrível. Você traz temas muito
profundos e complexos de forma simples
e e constrói slides com uma maestria que
eu ainda preciso aprender com você. É,
eu tô eh quero aprender, olha só, eu
quero aprender com Alan e quero aprender
com o slide lá com o Rodrigo para
próximas lives, tá louca? Eles vão fazer
o curso pra gente, hein?
Não, eu fico impressionado. Eles estão
tão muito inseridos, né, nessa
tecnologia com muita facilidade, né?
Mas os
as as mães chegam para nós muitas vezes
eh com com diagnóstico feito
recentemente e elas não têm ideia do que
que tá diante delas. Eu costumo falar na
primeira consulta que na verdade e a
gente tá diante de uma desordem
sistêmica. Então eu abordo isso tudo com
elas, falo da individualização, falo de
todas as terapias que elas vão vão ter
vantagens em fazer, seguir com o
neuropediatra convencional, porque eles
podem ajudar muito, mas incluir também a
homeopatia, que é a minha especialidade,
e essa visão integrativa. Então eu
esclareço pra mãe de uma forma breve ah
a importância da suplementação
individualizada, de exames
complementares individualizados e de uma
homeopatia bem feita,
mas não muito extensa, mas o o simples
que funciona, porque muitas vezes a mãe
chega: "Ó, Lucas, eh, eu li em tal lugar
que esse método é bom, que essa terapia
é boa, que isso então e e tem livros
hoje sugerindo 400 métodos diferentes
para ajudar pacientes eh teia. Então, as
mães chegam perdidas. Lucas, dessas 400
que eu li, o que que realmente eu posso
seguir? Então, eu cito a especialidade
em médico
cito a nutrologia, a gente pode falar aí
de ortomolecular que faz esse olhar
individualizado da suplementação da
necessidade de cada um, como o Dr. Alan
falou muito bem, eh não existe uma
suplementação protocolar para todo mundo
igual, não existe. Não existe uma
vitamina milagrosa para todo mundo, não
existe. Assim como não existe uma
homeopatia milagrosa para todo mundo, na
verdade a gente vai ajudar esses
pacientes a se desenvolverem eh no
máximo do seu potencial que a gente
conseguir ajudar, que que é isso que a
gente quer. Eh, como é uma síndrome eh e
é ah multicausal, né? E e muitas vezes
até difícil fechar o esse diagnóstico, a
nossa função como profissionais é
esclarecer essa desordem sistêmica e
tentar ajudar. O que que eu vejo hoje
como médico? Eu vejo que o autismo vem
como desafio paraa medicina
convencional.
A medicina convencional para ela ter
bons resultados realmente com pacientes
autis, ela precisa transcender o olhar
cartesiano dela. Então é um calcanhar de
Aquiles da medicina hoje o autismo. Na
minha visão, o médico convencional para
ele ir além do risperidona e do
aripiprazol, ele vai precisar
transcender o olhar fragmentado que ele
tem do sujeito. Então ela vem, na
verdade, como um aprendizado paraa
medicina. a medicina vai começar a ter
bons resultados quando ela transcender o
olhar fragmentado e passar a ter o olhar
integrativo. Eu acredito muito nisso.
Bom, Lucas, ótimo. E eu só queria
perguntar pro Alan como é que ele junto
com a esposa de dele, a Dra. Ana Paula,
conseguiram eh
reverter um autismo grau três
para um grau um. Eu tive privilégio, eu,
Rodrigo, há 15 dias atrás conversar com
o Artur. Ficamos 3 horas conversando com
Artur. O Artur fala de todos os temas
possíveis que você possa imaginar.
tudo. A minha a minha esposa ficou
impressionada com Artur. Alan, eu eu Mas
queria te dar os parabéns primeiro pela
criação do teu filho junto com a tua
esposa, Ana Paula, que que vocês dois
fizeram um trabalho junto com todos os
profissionais do do que que vocês ela
convidaram para ajudar o Artur. Agora eu
queria que você me explicasse como é que
vocês dois conseguiram, já que na
clínica é são casos difícil grau três,
passar para dois, para para um.
Atualmente é uma pessoa eh esplêndida, é
é um ser humano completamente
interessante e que fala de todos os
assuntos. Ele falou com a gente na mesa
de todos os assuntos possíveis, tanto eu
como o Rodrigo, como o Rodrigo me ajudou
porque ele me fez perguntas
sobre tratamento meu pato. Rodrigo
interagiu comigo, lá respondi, ela me
ajudou que ele foi tão tão profundo que
eu fiquei confuso um pouco, tá? Alan.
Mas a questão é o seguinte, é eh o de
falar a verdade, Luís, a gente não pode
falar com toda a certeza que ele era
grau três, tal, e ficou essa dúvida no
começo porque ele não era verbal por
vários anos, né? Ele demorou muito para
começar a falar. Então, a gente pode
dizer que ele era grau três, mas
dependendo do ponto de vista podemos
dizer que ele era grau dois também, tá?
E hoje a gente pode falar com bastante
tranquilidade porque ele é grau um, né,
de cuidados. Ele é uma praticamente
normal, assim, ele tem só algumas
peculiaridades, né? Então, primeira
coisa que eu queria falar, a gente tem
que tomar muito cuidado com a
romantização, tá? Porque hoje tem um
movimento muito forte nas redes sociais
de romanticizar excessivamente o TEA.
Existe sim vários casos de tea leve de
grau de cuidado. Um, que são pessoas
praticamente normais, que o diagnóstico
é tardio na vida adulta, mas tá
acontecendo uma banalização de
diagnóstico, sim, tanto do TEA quanto do
TDAH. Tomem cuidado com alguns
influenciadores que estão buscando eh
mais views e mais cliques por se
autodenominando aí autistas e e nem
sempre são, tá? Não tô dizendo que não
tenha vários que sejam, mas tem alguns
que estão falando que são e não são e
estão dizendo aí como se todo autista
fosse de autodesempenho, de auto eh
questão de eh de auto Qi. Não é assim.
Tem muitos casos de autista que são
crianças que t baixo eh questão
intelectual. Então, cuidado com a
romantização. Então, a gente tem que
ajudar cada indivíduo individualmente,
eh, sem buscar protocolos, sem buscar
tratamentos generalizados para todos,
como foi bem falado aí durante essa
live. E a gente tem que entender que
existe sim eh autistas altamente
inteligentes, autistas altamente
capazes, mas também tem autistas que
nunca vão ser verbais. vão ter autistas
que têm problemas sérios aí de doenças
eh associadas como a síndrome de R, como
a a síndo X frágio. Então, tomem cuidado
também com isso, tá? Não vamos eh
romantizar demais, porque são múltiplas
doenças e no mesmo guarda-chuva, tá?
Então queria falar isso porque existe
essa questão que tá um pouco exagerada
hoje em dia. A gente tem que tomar um
extremo cuidado com isso. Agora
responder tua pergunta, Luiz, por causa
do do a melhora do do Artur foi
principalmente uma combinação intensa de
muita investimento em terapia
ocupacional, em fonudiologia, em várias
terapias psicológicas. terapia aba no
início para ele foi importante, depois
passou a não ser mais importante, mas no
começo foi importante. E foi bem na
época que eu tava fazendo a minha
transição, quando eu atu era criança
pequena, 2 anos de idade, eu comecei a
minha transição eh de médico ortodoxo
para para médico que começou a estudar
ortomolecular, começou a estudar
medicina funcional. Então, eh,
realmente, eh, junto com meus problemas
de saúde que eu tinha na época, que era
enxaqueca crônica, intestina irritável e
também os problemas de saúde da minha
esposa e dele, a gente foi curando
primeiro, ou curando, não é a palavra,
desculpe, mas a gente foi melhorando eh
primeiro os problemas de saúde meu, da
minha esposa, do meu filho, todas as
doenças crônicas e muito difícil de de
lidar para depois eu estender isso
paraos meus pacientes e mudar
completamente a minha atuação como
médico, né, que eu era urologista
totalmente ortodoxo.
falava que essa coisa de gluto era tudo
besteira, falava que tudo era besteira,
eu era assim. Então, eh, realmente o atu
foi produto de uma investimento muito
intenso, eh, de terapias múltiplas,
tanto terapia ocupacional como fono,
como psicólogo, como eh suplementação
bastante
precisa em termos assim das deficiências
que ele tinha. Ele tinha um ferro muito
baixo, ele tinha uma questão de
deficiência de ômega-3, ele tinha uma
deficiência de vitamina D. Então, a
gente foi melhorando cada uma dessas
características, entrando também com a
questão do sono, que ele tinha um sono
bem ruim, então a gente melhorou o sono
dele com melatonina, com gaba, eh, com
uma série de substâncias aí precursoras
da taurina. Então, assim, cada autista é
um autista. Eu não tô pretendendo aqui
dar nenhum protocolo, nem uma receita de
bolo para ninguém, porque não funciona
assim, pessoal, tá? Você viu que eu eu
apresentei dois casos clínicos e um
deles não era o meu filho, tá? Isso foi
proposital para mostrar que o tratamento
pode ser diferente. Por exemplo, para
para uma das crianças a gente usou muito
mais tratamento mitocondrial, paraa
outra a gente usou muito mais o
tratamento intestinal. Então isso é isso
é individualizado. A gente tem que
pensar no ser humano como um todo, no
indivíduo, né? Esse é um grande
problema, eu acho, da medicina mais
ortodoxa, é de você reduzir o indivíduo
à doença que ele tem. Então é aquela
enxaqueca, é aquele câncer, é aquela
doença X ou Y Z. Isso tá totalmente
errado. A gente tem que olhar o
indivíduo primeiro antes de tudo. Mesmo
indivíduo autista, mesmo que ele não
seja verbal, ele continua sendo um
indivíduo e não simplesmente tratá-lo
como aquela criança agitada que tem que
tacar esperidona ou aripipasol, que são
os dois únicos remédios, como Lucas
falou, que são aprovados aí para
tratamentos. Eh, e ainda não são nenhum
sintomas principais, são sintomas
periféricos do autismo.
Pessoal, acabou. Ô, Alan.
Sim, sim. Já falei demais até acho.
Imagina. Pessoal, eu só queria falar
mais uma coisinha que eu acho que faz
muito sentido. Eh, eu posso só eh falar
sobre o Before The Doctor. Before The
Doctor, na verdade é uma loja que eu e a
Charlene Cicron montamos, que lá nós
temos toda a parte de produtos,
exatamente, para não contaminar mais o
terreno biológico. Então esse aqui é só
para mostrar os casos minimamente
invasivos com resinas sem, né, a
estética integrativa, ela tem que cuidar
disso também. Então cuidado e estética.
E aqui é o Before the Doctor, que todos
os produtos são exatamente para que a
gente não contaminhe. Então tem ch eh
filtro de chuveiro, filtro de água.
A gente pode colocar na tela isso, hein,
Rodrigo? A gente pode colocar na tela.
Ah, desculpa, não tá, não tá. E agora
tá.
Pera aí que eu vou eu vou colocar
pera aí que vou eh não, você vai ter que
colocar de novo, Rodrigo,
o a sua
Rodrigo, queria colocasse isso e queria
que você colocasse também do SIS
também isso também, tá? Ô Rodrigo,
oi.
Eu tô procurando aqui de novo, então,
apresentar,
compartilhar tela. Eu queria colocasse
também aquele convite do SIS também, por
favor.
Ah, sim, já coloco já. Partilhar. E
agora dá para ver?
Hum. Deixa eu ver aqui. Ah, tá.
Apareceu. Apareceu.
Hum. Então esse aqui é os são os casos
estéticos, né, que a gente faz
minimamente invasivo, sem desgastar o
dente, como se coloca, se desgasta o
dente para fazer faceta, só se
acrescenta praticamente, né, usando
resinas que são sem BPA, né? Eh, esse
aqui é o Before The Doctor, que tem,
então, é a loja que tem maquiagens,
shampoos, limpa vidro, eh, filtros,
filtro de água, filtro de chuveiro para
tirar o cloro e o e o fluor, né? Tudo
que que a homeopatia trabalha para
desintoxicar, a gente tem na loja para
evitar que se recontamine. Eu acho que
era só importante falar, né, e falar que
todos os produtos têm eh são foram muito
bem selecionados e tem também todos os
suplementos que a gente utiliza. Ah,
essa aqui são as minhas mídias, né?
Então tem o Q code aqui se alguém tiver
interesse. E vamos voltar lá no no
convite mais uma vez pro CIS que a gente
vai fazer mais uma
mais esse simpósio internacional de
saúde integrativa com esses feras, né,
ô Alan, que você é fera.
É verdade. Eu tenho que voltar a falar
esse meu bordão. Parei de falar nos
vídeos, viu? Eh, a gente fez uma uma
live junto, ficou bem gravado, eu, você
e o Ícaro. Mas então, vai acontecer dia
13, 14 e 15 de março. Contamos com a
presença de vocês que estão interessados
em saber mais sobre o Alzheimer, mais
sobre a homeopatia, como que a
homeopatia vem ajudar e também a
prevenir, né, a melhorar a memória, todo
o terreno biológico. vão ter vários
professores, então a gente utilizou a
forma de pensar do recod, então desde
estress pessoas falando sobre como
melhorar toda a parte de estess
oxidativo, mudança de hábitos com doutor
Ícaro. A gente vai ter limpeza, terreno
biológico de forma biofísica, forma
bioquímica,
natural, conexão do dente com o corpo.
Bom, enfim,
entra em contato aqui para vocês verem a
programação. Vai ser um prazer ter vocês
todos aí. E queria mais uma vez
agradecer a todos vocês que tiveram
juntos aí conosco, né? Agradecer o Dr.
Lucas, Dr. Luiz, Dr. Alan Dutra.
Vocês querem ver só alguns comentários o
que eu selecionei durante a live? Vocês
tm 15 minutos ainda?
Vamos.
Perfeito. A pergunta que um farmacêutico
fez aqui,
eu não sei qual curso você tá falando,
eu não sei se é o curso de homeopatia
básica ou se o, enfim, vocês podem
responder essa pergunta aí.
Se for o nosso curso de mentoria,
homeopatia e pediatria, eh, não pode,
porque ele é para presor. Então, como
farmacêutico não faz diagnóstico e
tratamento, eh, no, eh, segundo o CRM, a
gente não pode abrir para farmacêutico,
infelizmente.
Foi importante de esclarecer isso aí.
Tranquilo.
É uma boa pergunta essa aí. Que que
vocês me dizem? Sim. Olha só, a minha
esposa, os três filhos usou, não teve
efeito colateral, não tem problema. A
gente usa há mais ou menos 43 anos e
nunca tivemos problema, entendeu? Mas
ela, mas ela pode usar, né, Lucas? Esse
assunto é importantíssimo porque na
gestação, quanto mais a gente estuda
autismo, mais a gente vê que evitar
remédios na gestação, de remédios
convencionais
é melhor, porque quanto mais eh
quanto mais estudos são publicados, mais
a gente vê que remédios químicos podem
sim afetar o cérebro em do bebê em
desenvolvimento do feto ainda
intrauterano. pode passar a a placenta e
afetar o feto em desenvolvimento. Então,
quanto mais eu estudo, mais eu vejo que
a homeopatia é a melhor opção para
gestante, para qualquer queixa, gestante
com dor lombar, gestante com enxaqueca,
gestante com eh edema de membros
inferiores, gestante com insônia, eh
gestante com até com depressão. a
homeopatia pode ajudar de forma
individualizada todos esses casos e o e
os estudos mostram que realmente muitas
classes de medicamentos, isso eu dou até
no meu curso, eh qual o efeito de
antidepressivo na gestação e o que isso
pode afetar o bebê, anticonvulsivante,
antibiótico, enfim, eh eh hormônios, eh
ultrogestã, muitas gestantes usam
trogestã. Então tudo isso a gente tem
estudos e como que isso pode afetar?
Então, quanto mais a gente estuda,
quanto mais artigos são publicados, mas
a gente tem certeza que tem que ter
muito cuidado na prescrição de remédios
para gestante. A homeopatia é uma boa
opção.
E aquela questão do número de avogrados
se serve como crítica também, nesse caso
serve como, né, uma coisa que ajuda, né,
homeopatia, né?
É, você falou eh muito bem, Alan, no
início dessa live que a homeopatia é uma
medicina informacional. Ela leva uma
informação pro indivíduo, não leva uma
química chave receptor, né? Ela leva uma
informação. E o nosso organismo ele é
informacional, né? A gente tem um
arcabolso informacional que é a base pro
para para pro nosso corpo material e a
homeopatia nesse arcabolso que é além da
matéria. Então é um é um remédio
imaterial. Ele é informacional, como se
fosse um software do nosso organismo. No
computador você tem o hardware, que é a
parte material do computador, e você tem
o software, que é a parte informacional.
É aí que a homeopatia atua.
Perfeito. Essa pergunta da Dra. Ana
Paula aí, que que você diz sobre ela?
Com doença autoimune que tem crises na
gestação, pode ter risco aumentado
também. Eh, eu não vi especificamente
artigos todos que eu li, eh, a
correlação de doença autoimune na
gestação, eh, e a incidência de autismo
na pró. Não sei se Dr. Alan, Rodrigo, o
Dr. Luiz tem essa informação. O que a
gente tem aqui anti-inflamatórios e
corticóes e alguns remédios utilizados
para tratar essas doenças autoimune.
Sim, esses remédios podem afetar eh e
aumentar a incidência em alguns casos de
autismo na prolle, mas a doença
autoimune em si, muitas vezes, inclusive
na janela gestacional, as doenças
autoimunes tende a melhorar o quadro
clínico, né? E e muitas vezes a a
gestante ela ela consegue deixar de
tomar os os remédios paraa doença
autoimune dela, porque a gestação ela é
a imunossupressora naturalmente, né?
Então, muitas vezes a doença autoimune
ela tem uma remissão temporária durante
o período gestacional. alguns casos
depois do do parto, eu já presenciei
isso, tem um rebote. Então, a aquela
doença autoimune silencia durante o
período gestacional, depois que ocorre o
nascimento do bebê, aquela doença que a
mulher, que a gestante já tinha, ela
volta com mais força, né,
Lucas? Perfeito.
E a gente acompanha pessoas muito com
lupos, artritumatoide, síndrome de
jogreem, tudo. Eu acho que o próprio
remédio homeopata, ele como atua, como
você estava falando, dessa forma
informativa,
ele estimula a força vital, tá? E e ele
estimula as células boas a combaterem
essas células ruins do que que o corpo
assim produz. Então eu vejo caso, eu
tenho alguns casos de de lupos, artrite
reamatid de jogren, que o os exames após
o média homeopata, a gente vê que ela
diminui a proteína serreativa, valex, o
vale rose eh látex e a gente vê as
células le e que a gente vai
acompanhando e tudo e tem um um canal
pra gente atuar bem com o próprio
remédio de homeopata sempre estimulando
a força vital. A gente não tá passando
mais aquela substância química, a gente
não tá passando a matéria do arsênico.
Eu não tô passando o hélio, eu tô
passando uma coisa que estimula é a
função daquela substância, entendeu? Mas
imaterial, arsênico, poélio, cadmi,
essas coisas assim nesse sentido.
Pergunta pro Dr. Rodrigo aí. Só eu
publiquei recentemente um artigo que
fala exatamente sobre essas síndromes.
Ah, o Extenbar ele tá muito relacionado
a elas na literatura e o osten bar tá
muito relacionado à sua presença ao
redor do dente, tanto dentro do dente
como também ao redor dele. Então, tanto
no áice como também no periodonto.
E a gente tem visto bastante epistem
bast megalovírus, né, da família do
Firid relacionados a isso, lupsomatoso,
artrite reumatoide, câncer também. E a
gente tem estudado bastante isso. E a a
odontologia quando tira a favela, vamos
dizer assim, né? Eh, quando você tira só
os invasores, vamos dizer assim, da
casa, eles podem acabar voltando. Então,
muitas vezes você tem que tirar a casa
ou retratando um canal ou fazendo uma
extração e a gente tem visto melhoras
incríveis.
Uhum. Olha só, Rodrigo, eu
deixa ele só responder essa pergunta
rapidinho. Ô, pergunta, achei bem
interessante essa pergunta aí, Rodrigo,
quer responder?
É para mim durante a gravidez a
exposição ao mercúrio no trabalho, caso
de dentista e outros profissionais e no
consumo de peixes contaminados pode
levar comentar de autismo. Sim, pode
sim. Principalmente a gente citou um
trabalho aqui no início mostrando que
mulheres que t
seis ou ou mais amálgamas dentais tem
3,2 vezes mais chances de ter risco de
autismo. Então o mercúrio que é liberado
das restaurações de mercúrio, né, eh
pode estar relacionado a isso, assim
como também a gente sabe que algumas
vacinas elas têm algumas, tá? Não tô
falando que são todas, mas algumas têm o
etilcúrio, que é utilizado tanto para
espalhar como também para eh conter,
vamos dizer assim, os vírus. Então, a o
peixe também, a,
a
o mercúrio que um peixinho grande acaba
comendo, né, que o atum, por exemplo, o
peixe espada, ele acaba ficando
contaminado com aquele mercúrio.
Infelizmente nós dentistas acabamos
removendo as restaurações de amargama
dental e jogando tudo no esgoto.
Hoje a gente aqui na clínica a gente
contém isso, não joga mais, mas é um
hábito que precisamos criar essa
consciência pro meio ambiente, né, para
evitar exatamente a contaminação desses
peixes que a gente acaba comendo depois.
OK? Olha só, mas só para terminar, eu só
queria falar uma coisa lá, Rodrigo, por
causa de você e e e das tuas lives, do
teu estudo, todo paciente meu agora novo
do que eu atendo de câncer, ele tem que
ele tem que fazer uma revisão
odontológica, porque eu vi vários casos
apresentados que não tava andando o caso
de câncer com quimioterapia,
radioterapia e após o tratamento
odontológico, o quadro mudou
completamente. Então, por isso que por
causa desses casos, eu falei para mim
mesmo, eu tenho que fazer alguma junção
de ortomolecular, medicina integrativa,
eu tenho que convidar pessoas que possam
integrar esse processo do que que a
gente quer fazer, entendeu? Agora,
Rodrigo, aí você pode terminar só com
isso, falando um pouquinho só da
importância da saúde blocal para câncer
atualmente.
Sim, claro. O mercúrio ele é um que
altera a leitura do RNA para o DNA, né?
Então ele vai interferir e pode tá
ligado ao câncer. A gente viu hoje o FL
que também pode estar ligado ao câncer.
A gente viu também mercanos que são
produzidos em restos necróticos de
canais que não conseguiram ser tratados,
não porque o dentista seja ruim, mas por
causa da diversidade anatômica das
raízes, dificulta isso e pode acabar
também causando uma diminuição da
limpeza do nosso do nosso citocromo P4
150, que são aquelas enzimas que vão
limpar a nossa cozinha, vão chegar lá e
vão falar: "Ah, vamos limpar aqui".
Então a nossa célula, quando isso
diminui, acaba ficando suja e entra a
célula num processo de homotoxicose. E a
última fase da homotoxicose é a
desdiferenciação.
Daí você também tem os vírus que adoram
ficar dentro dos dentes e também nós
temos muito ligado ao câncer, um
trabalho do Lner que é um alemão que ele
mostra que as cavitações óseas fazem com
que aumente em muito o CCL5, que é uma
citocina que tá ligada em mais de 9410
artigos de revisões de de câncer. Então
são vários fatores que levam ao câncer.
Eh, que vai ser um prazer tá falando no
curso de vocês sobre isso, com mais
detalhes.
Tá bom. A agora, gente, ah, só para
terminar, mais ou menos um minuto para
cada um para pra gente terminar, Lucas,
as palavras finais. Eu
acredito muito que a gente tá caminhando
para um outro nível de consciência,
tanto da medicina, da odontologia. Minha
mãe foi aluna do Dr. Mário Baldani da
Biociibbernética bucal. Minha mãe é
dentista. Isso lá na década de 80 e 90.
Então eu já nasci com essa visão
ampliada tanto na parte da saúde bucal.
Minha mãe eh cura eh enxaquecas e outras
doenças usando a técnica da
biociibernética bucal. que atualmente
essa odontologia biológica deu
continuidade, provavelmente, né? Mas eu
acredito que tanto os pacientes quanto
os profissionais de saúde eh tão
integrando aquilo tudo que a gente de
forma cartesiana separou para estudar,
esqueceu de juntar. Então agora a gente
chegou numa fase da medicina que a gente
tá vendo especialistas igual o Dr. Alan,
que estão deixando de ser especialista,
mantém aquele conhecimento, mas ele tá
ampliando com uma visão global do
paciente. A homeopatia é uma boa opção
para isso, que ela naturalmente, desde a
sua origem, ela olha pro paciente como
um todo e prescreve pro paciente como um
todo. Então, juntar os pedaços, ter um
olhar global, principalmente para
queixas que são desordens sistêmicas. A
gente obrigatoriamente para poder ajudar
esses pacientes, a gente precisa
transcender o reducionismo, o
materialismo,
eh, e esse cartesianismo da fragmentação
e ter um olhar integral pro paciente. E
na, na minha prática do Luís e aí de
vocês, a gente também tem o recurso da
homeopatia.
Hum. Alan, perfeito.
As últimas palavras tuas aí, Alan.
Vou te dar a chave do canal para você
tocar o canal, hein?
Últimas palavras. Não, só queria
agradecer a presença dos dos amigos aqui
que se tornaram grandes amigos e também
são excelentes profissionais cada um da
sua área e agradecer a oportunidade de
tá aprendendo cada vez mais com vocês e
tá proporcionando esse conteúdo aí de
alta qualidade pros internautas que
acompanham meu trabalho no meu canal no
YouTube. Lembrar novamente aí do
congresso SIS, lembrar novamente aí do
curso do Dr. Luiz Stern, Dr. Lucas
Pacheco, eles estão oferecendo aí pros
profissionais médicos, então e vocês
acompanharem o conteúdo deles nas redes
sociais, né? Já colocamos aí o Instagram
do Dr. Rodrigo, o @ do seu Instagram,
qual que é? Luiz
Sterne. Luizne,
@luestterne, né? É só isso. E do Lucas
qualquer
dr. Llucashoneia.
DR. Llucas. Tem o ponto Lucas, né? eh,
homeopatia. Então, acompanhe o trabalho
desses profissionais. Esse com certeza
vale muito a pena. São profissionais
excelentes e que agregaram muito aí,
influenciaram muito nesses últimos anos
aí da nossa jornada em conjunto para
tratar nossos pacientes
e agradecer a presença de todos vocês
que estão acompanhando a live.
Tá bom.
Pronto. As últimas palavras, Rodrigo, lá
pra gente terminar. agradecer mais mais
uma vez essa oportunidade de estar
compartilhando e aprendendo com vocês e
em enfatizar que o melhor caminho é
sempre a prevenção. Então, prevenir é o
melhor remédio. Por isso que a gente
aqui na clínica a gente sempre trabalha
na prevenção, mesmo da respiração,
ensinando a mãe a amamentar, a
importância disso que tem em toda parte
da estrutura, né? A sua mãe ortopedista,
que maravilha. É muito importante. Eu
tive a formação, meu pai e minha mãe são
dentistas também. minha minhas duas
irmãs são dentistas, minha tia é
dentista, minha prima é dentista, minha
bisavó é dentista. Então a gente disse
que na verdade é uma missão familiar,
né? Mas queria só agradecer vocês pela
oportunidade.
Um karma, né? Gente, eu queria terminar
a live também falando, né? que para mim
é super importante é essa integração lá
com vocês.
Ou seja, mas cada aula do que que eu
escuto do Alan, do Lucas, Rodrigo e
tudo, eu fico mais estimulado e e eu
queria fazer o convite. Eu tenho 50
temas para fazer com vocês os próximos
meses. A gente vai fazer uma já sobre
Alzheimer, cérebro e aí também velice,
saúde cerebral. Eh, a gente vai fazer no
último domingo de janeiro, se por acaso
do vocês três toparem. Tá bom.
Tá fechado.
Tá fechado, Lucas.
Ah, por mim tá fechado.
Combinado. E olha, muita gratidão a
todos vocês pela oportunidade de estar
aqui também. Admiro muito o trabalho de
todos vocês, viu? Parabéns por tudo que
vocês estão fazendo pela medicina e pela
odontologia.
Gratidão.
Alan. Fechado. Alan.
Fechado.
Então, tá bom.
Acho que sim. Acho que sim. Se eu não
aparecer outra coisa aí para para
bloquear, mas acho que vai dar sim. Mas
a gente pode aqui mesmo, né, no nosso
canal ou ou quer fazer no Instagram?
Não, tá ótimo aqui
no YouTube mesmo. Então tá bom.
É aqui mesmo. Tá bom. Tá.
Tá joia. Então e agora você vai ser o o
o meu rosto das outras lives, hein? Vou
vou pegar você para ficar apresentando
as minhas lives para não ficar me
preocupando com isso, tá certo?
Tá bom. Então, valeu. Então,
abraço para todo mundo, ó. Excelente ano
para todo mundo. Ela muita saúde, paz e
proteção do que a gente consiga aliviar
o sofrimento de tanta gente ela que tá
sofrendo com tanta doença crônica, eh eh
com tanto câncer aparecendo, autismo,
Paxon, Alzheimer, caso de CTI, entendeu?
Então, é uma coisa e a nossa função
atualmente é transmitir e em alguma
ideia nova, estimular mais as pessoas a
procurarem caminho que possa aliviar o
sofrimento eh sofrimento do ser humano e
cada um tentar cumprir o seu papel de
uma forma mais digna possível na vida,
encontrando a sua missão, o seu
propósito.
Perfeito, pessoal. Muito obrigado pela
presença de vocês. Obrigado a todos aí
que estão assistindo e até a próxima
live, pessoal. Tchau. Tchau.
Abraço. Tchau. Tchau. Fique com
Valeu, gente. Obrigado aí pela presença,
hein.